Hallo, hallo. Ich habe gesehen, es gibt gerade den finalen Playtest. Ich glaube, der Stream
ist gar nicht richtig an. Doch, ist er. WTF? Ich dachte, ich habe nicht auf Play gedrückt
richtig. Ich muss meine Vorschau nochmal refreshen, da wird nämlich nichts angezeigt.
Ja, also, es gibt gerade den finalen Playtest von Battle.Bit Remastered. Das läuft noch
ungefähr eine Stunde. Und ich dachte mir, wir gucken uns das jetzt einfach mal an. Ich
habe vorhin, also insgesamt, ich habe die letzten paar Playtests immer mal wieder gespielt.
Und ich wollte mir das einfach nochmal angucken, wie das jetzt so ist. Also, die letzten Playtests
über war ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig begeistert von. Aber mal gucken, mal gucken. Also ich
meine, es ist so ein bisschen Battlefield im Minecraft-Look, könnte man vielleicht sagen.
Wobei, ja, ich glaube, das trifft es eigentlich am besten so. Ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so
schlecht beschrieben. Zumindest, moin Max. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt die komplette
Stunde hier durchhalte. Mal gucken. Also, die letzten Male war ich, wie gesagt, nicht so
begeistert. War noch sehr unfertig. Aber gut, ich meine, es ist ja auch noch nicht mal Early
Access. Es ist quasi noch, noch vor Release. Also noch weit vor Early Access Release. Na ja,
weit vor Early Access Release nicht. Early Access Release sehen wir irgendwann nächste Woche. Ja,
aber wie gesagt, ich war nicht so sonderlich begeistert von der Grafik. Nicht so sehr,
weil es Minecraft-Look ist, sondern weil man die Gegner halt sehr schlecht teilweise gesehen hat auf
Wänden und Hintergründen und sowas. Und dass man auch nicht richtig die Tiefe in der Map erkannt
hat. Kaum Schatten und sowas. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Mal gucken, ob das taugt. Ich habe,
wie gesagt, insgesamt die letzten Playtests mal immer mal wieder ein bisschen gespielt. Vorhin
installiert, mal eine Runde reingejoint und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, komm, wenn du das jetzt eh
ausprobierst, dann kannst du jetzt auch mal Stream anmachen und gucken. Mal ganz kurz was zu trinken
einschenken und was trinken und dann können wir anfangen. Du bist geploggt auf der Webseite.
Welcher Webseite? Auf Twitch. Ist das ein neuer Account? Probieren wir das mal aus. Also ich starte
das Ganze mal. Wir machen mal kurz hier die Back-Company-Musik aus und wir müssen jetzt
erstmal checken, ob die Lautstärke korrekt ist. Easy-Anti-Cheat-und-Geschiss habe ich
alle schon installiert im Vorfeld. Jetzt gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an. Natürlich Unity,
was sonst? Wobei das ja weder jetzt für noch gegen das Game spricht. Unity hat ja nur so einen
schlechten Ruf, weil ja so zu Zeiten von Slenderman und sowas die ganzen Crap-Games immer mit Unity
gebastelt wurden. Wir kriegen sogar einen Trailer, den man nicht skippen kann. Es gibt sogar einen
Trailer. Ich mach ein Stückchen lauter mal. Es gibt sogar einen Trailer, was, wer muss schon sagen,
was sowohl von Aufmachung und Musik doch schon sehr an Battlefield angelehnt ist. By the way,
das Game hat sich letztes Mal überhaupt nicht so gespielt wie hier im Trailer. Es war viel
langsamer als Battlefield und viel mehr Gestälze und Fenstergekämpfe und sowas. Aber mal gucken,
wie sich das jetzt im letzten Playtest geändert hat. xQc hat das auch gespielt, okay. Und was hat
er gesagt? Machst du aktuell auf der Arbeit irgendwelche Kurse und Weiterbildung? Nee. Ach
ja und ein Kritikpunkt, an den ich mich noch erinnern kann aus den letzten Playtests. Man
sieht absolut nicht, was ein und wer einen gekillt hat. Ihr werdet es vielleicht, also ich hoffe nicht,
dass es immer noch so schlimm ist. Ihr werdet es aber gleich sehen. Also du platzt einfach,
du hast absolut keine Ahnung. War das jetzt eine Granate? War das ein Sniper? War das irgendwas?
Du weißt es einfach nicht. Okay, wir aggregen. Chat, aggreget ihr auch? Das geht nur,
wenn wir alle aggregen. Einmal bitte aggrege in den Chat. Ich möchte meinen Voice Chat bitte
ausschalten. Ich habe jetzt hier mein Mikro dran. Ich habe keinen Bock, dass die mich alle hören.
Ich habe nicht accepted. Alles gut. Auf Englisch. Lass mal kurz in die Settings gehen. Okay, geht
schon los. Wo sind denn die Settings überhaupt? Audio, wir müssen erstmal. Wenn ich das hier
aus habe, Opt in Voice Chat, dann habe ich das wahrscheinlich aus. Okay, ich wähle mal irgendwas
aus, was nicht angeschlossen ist als Mikrofon, weil ich habe echt keinen Bock, dass ich die
jetzt die ganze Zeit voll labere. In Game, das muss ja nicht sein. Wir machen aber Voice Chat
mal an. Voice Chat ist immer lustig, wenn dann irgendwelche Russen in Game rumschreien und so
was. So, ansonsten keine Ahnung. Mic Volume runter. Gibt es Push to Talk? Okay, keine Ahnung. Okay,
Apply. Und das Erste, was ich eigentlich ganz gut fand immer, mal im Vergleich jetzt zu den
letzten Battlefields, man kann seinen Soldier tatsächlich ziemlich stark customisen. Wo
ging das nochmal? Also, man kann nicht nur Attachments und so Zeug an die Waffen machen,
wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo das war. Keine Ahnung. Habe ich das rausgenommen? Grafik? Nee,
Grafik muss man hier nichts einstellen. Was willst du bei dem Game einstellen?
Was willst du hier einstellen? Field of View 90 ist okay, standardmäßig. Graphics, ihr werdet es
gleich sehen, weil da gibt es nicht viel einzustellen. Motion Blur muss auf jeden Fall
aus. Der Rest ist Crap. Also, man konnte seinen Soldier eigentlich relativ gut customisen. Das
fand ich jetzt persönlich recht nice. Aber mal gucken, vielleicht geht das nicht mehr. Schauen
wir mal. Also, wie gesagt, ihr werdet sehen, so sieht die Grafik von dem Ding aus. Also,
man kann das jetzt nicht wirklich mit Battlefield vergleichen, aber es möchte so ein bisschen
Battlefield sein. My account will be banned from the server. Okay, nice, alles klar. So,
wir spielen. Jaja, das weiß ich, wie das funktioniert. Medic wollen wir spielen. Continue
Medic. So, jetzt kann man seinen Loadout customisen. Da können wir zum Beispiel an unsere M4
verschiedenes Zeug dran machen. Ich habe aber, wie gesagt, noch viel zu wenig unlockt. Wobei
das standardmäßig durchaus in Ordnung ist. Braucht man alles nicht. Aber das finde ich schon mal ganz
gut gemacht für so ein kleines Game. Und man kann seinen Charakter auch customisen. Und das ist nicht
nur rein optisch, sondern man kann auch verschiedene, also man kann stärkere Rüstung und sowas drauf
machen, dass man ein bisschen langsamer ist und sowas. Ob es wirklich viel Auswirkung auf das
Game hat? Naja, naja, sei mal dahingestellt. Ich würde sagen, wir spawnen da jetzt einfach mal rein
und checken jetzt erstmal, ob die Lautstärke okay ist. Lasst mal kurz checken. Lautstärke ist ein
bisschen leise, oder? Ne, geht eigentlich. Lautstärke ist relativ okay. Schaust du gleich
die Xbox Präsentation? Ja, warum nicht? Wann ist denn die? So, eine Sache, die ich in dem Game bis
heute nicht gecheckt habe. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja insgesamt auch nur irgendwie, ja, genau, vier oder
fünf Stunden gespielt. Ach so, man muss sich übrigens bandagieren, wenn man gehittet wird. In
zwei Minuten. Ja, ne, dann nicht. Guck, dead. Man stirbt auch saumäßig schnell, wenn man gehittet
wird. Ja, man weiß, man weiß oftmals nicht so genau, von wo man beschossen wird. Das ist so ein
bisschen sad, gell? Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das, ob das ein Freund oder ein Feind war. Ich
glaube, das war ein Feind. Okay, was auch immer. Ich habe absolut, ist das Haus gerade explodiert,
oder so? Ich habe absolut keinen Schimmer, was mich gerade gekillt hat. Okay, wo ist C? Die Flangen
sieht man nämlich auch nicht richtig. Wo ist C? C, Leute, ich will zu C. C ist, C ist ergeblich
direkt vor mir. Und ich sehe, ach da, da, guck mal, da ist C. Das fällt kaum auf. Ich glaube,
wir müssen hier außenrum flanken. Guck so, bam, du bist, du bist, du weißt nicht, du weißt nicht,
von wo. Genau das gleiche Problem hatte ich bisher in den Playtests immer. Also es ist viel,
also wenn man das, wenn man sich ein bisschen Mühe geben will beim Spielen, das ist viel,
viel langsamer als, als, jeder Typ ist einfach afk. So, hüpfen wir mal hier hoch. Guck mal,
da ist mit seiner Drohne rumgestelzt gerade. Nice. Und man wird tatsächlich hier ab und zu
auch mal sogar revived. Okay, der Typ ist wirklich afk. Was aber nicht schlecht ist,
so als mobiler Spawnpoint. Ich bin mir wirklich unschlüssig, wo hier was ist. Wir müssen mal
gucken, ob wir hier irgendwie an der Seite lang, lang flanken können. Wir müssen hier offensichtlich
Richtung C und dann Richtung B. Die Häuser sind auch nicht sonderlich logisch aufgebaut. Ach ja,
und man kann Wände kaputt machen. Das sieht dann so ein bisschen aus wie... Okay,
da sind tatsächlich Gegner. So, und der Medic hat so eine, hat so eine Rauchgranate,
so wie der Typ hier auf der Gas. Da gehen wir jetzt, wir gehen jetzt mal runter. Die
Magazine, also das Reload ist Magazin-based, also wenn man Magazin leer geschossen hat,
kann man das trotzdem wieder nachladen, hat dann aber weniger, weniger Schuss. Okay,
nice. Oh oh, Claymore, nice. Sehr schön. Vielleicht kann er mich reviven, wenn die Bock
haben. Oh, ich werde revived. 5000 Euro PC für sowas. Ich muss erstmal halbwegs checken,
wo die Gegner... Da hinten. Also die sterben schnell, also das Spiel hat glaube ich einen
relativ hohen Headshot-Multiplier. Nee, das sind alles meine Dudes. Da hinten waren ganz
viele Gegner. Okay, ich höre Schüsse einschlagen. Ich habe legit keinen Schimmer von wo, aber
da waren auf jeden Fall welche. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man die Steine kaputt schießen
kann. Oh, das ist in die Body-Armor rein. Ist das Free-to-Play? Aktuell schon, ab nächster
Woche ist es Early-Access. Ging da ganz schön auf den Sack, kann das sein? So, wir capturen
den C. Das heißt, wir stehen in C, würde ich vermuten. Äh, okay, nice. Wow, ist das
der Dead-Guy? Ob das Dead-Guy... Ah, der hat released. Er sieht ein bisschen aus wie Free-to-Play,
das stimmt schon. Oh, ich dachte, da ist einer. Ich rette dich. Nice. Also, als Medic, deswegen
spiele ich immer Medic, weil sonst keiner rettet. Jetzt rasten sie aus. Okay, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, wo es lang geht, aber wir versuchen mal zu flanken. Irgendwie hier so lang. In der
Hoffnung, das checken die nicht. Ist das meiner? Ist das ein Auto von meinem Dude? Ich glaube,
ich glaube schon. Ich glaube auch, dass das ein Claymore ist von meinem Team. Was ich auch immer
nicht... Ich erkenne die Flaggenpunkte immer unglaublich schlecht. Okay, C. Ja, es hat ein
bisschen was von Cranker, wobei Cranker viel, viel schneller ist und viel mehr rumgejumpt und
gerennt. So, vielleicht erkennen wir auf der Karte irgendwie was, wo es hingeht. Aha, hier,
die Richtung ist schon mal nicht verkehrt. Das hat er sich ja anders vorgestellt. Er ist mal
runtergetroppt und gehatschottet. Oh, da drüben, direkt gegenüber. Ich werfe eine Smoke, die viel
zu langsam aktuell sind und dann auch noch ewig brauchen, bis sie smoken. Oh, shit. Hätte ich
fast gehabt. Guck mal, die ersten hier schon mit zwei. Werde ich gerettet? Oh, massive rest. Und
ich werde gehealt. Übrigens, ich glaube, ich weiß, wie man healt als Medic. Man muss die Medic-Tasche
rausnehmen und einfach nur bei den Teammates stehen. Bandage, Bandage, Bandage. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob man sich selbst heilen kann, wenn man das so hält. Was muss man machen zum
heilen? X? X? Nee. Pick up? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man heilt. Wie heilt man dann? So,
schon mal nicht. So, ich bin eh instant dead, wenn ich jetzt hier rüberrenne. Ich habe kaum
noch Leben. Was, glaube ich, gar keine Gegner waren. Doch, das war ein Gegner. Voll hinkommen.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken. Ich habe nicht einmal allzu viel Schuss. Das ist jetzt sehr
Risiko. Oh, habt ihr gesehen? Da standen drei Gegner rum gerade. Hätte ich ein bisschen mehr
Schuss gehabt. So, wo müssen wir denn jetzt hin Richtung B? Es fühlt sich halt wirklich noch sehr
unfertig an. Aber okay, ich meine, es ist Early Access. Es ist noch nicht mal. Es ist ab nächster
Woche Early Access. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher. Mal ganz im Ernst, Grafik ist natürlich nicht
alles. Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen. Oh, die Runde ist vorbei. Oh, wir haben verloren. Ich
muss sagen, ich habe zwar prinzipiell nichts dagegen, gegen so minimalistische Grafik. Das
ist schon ganz in Ordnung. Was mir nicht gefällt, ist, dass man schlecht die Tiefe einschätzen kann
von vielen Sachen auf der Map. Also, du läufst beispielsweise rum und es gibt einen Tunnel auf
der Map und du erkennst gar nicht mal so richtig, dass es ein Tunnel ist. Und es ist auch alles super
detailarm. Und das liegt nicht an der Grafik, sondern weil einfach in keinen Gängen und in
keinen Häusern irgendwie nennenswert was drin ist. Die Häuser sind auch sehr, ähm, tja, was wollen
wir denn hier? Map? Keine Ahnung. Wie egal. Sind auch sehr unsinnig aufgebaut, so dass ein Haus
geteilt ist durch eine Wand in der Mitte, wo halt nirgendswo eine Tür durchgeht und sowas. Also,
ich glaube jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass das mehr wird als so ein ganz cooles Game nebenbei,
was vielleicht bei Release dann mal irgendwie so ein paar hundert Leute hat. Ich meine,
jetzt aktuell gibt es immer mal wieder Playtests, das ist komplett kostenlos. Aber sollte das dann
wirklich später was kosten und, ich weiß nicht. Das kommt ja so aus den paar Stunden Playtests,
die ich bisher gemacht habe, über die letzten paar Monate über. Wenn es Unleashed ist besser.
Wenn es Unleashed ist eigentlich mega nice. Wait a minute. Kamen hier irgendwelche Autos? Kann man
das fahren? Nö. Wenn es Unleashed ist eigentlich übelst nice. Leider haben die sich selbst
verkackt durch eh schon wenige Spieler und dann monatelang ein Memory Leak drin gehabt,
was das Game gecrashed hat nach zehn Minuten. Dürfen wir weiterlaufen? Ne, egal. Okay. Einfach
geradeaus. Ich glaube, das ist einfach gut für Leute im low-end-PCs. Weiß nicht. Ja,
auf jeden Fall, aber. Wow. Physics. Nehmen wir das mal ein. Es gibt zumindest keine Killstreaks
oder sowas. Ich glaube, ich habe sogar mal ein Video zugemacht. Damals war es aber komplett
unplayable noch. Da sind, da sind, da sind hier alle mega krass rumgeleckt. Und ich glaube,
da haben wir sogar die Map hier gespielt. Die Frage, geht es hier runter? Tatsächlich. Okay,
hier geht es nicht weiter. Jetzt halt die Frage, wo und wie kommt hier jetzt was lang? Okay. Erster
Dude dead. Oh shit. Haben wir uns gerade gegenseitig gekillt, Leute? Gekillt? By? Steht
das irgendwo? Talk? Habe ich den Typen auch gekillt? Weil ich glaube, wir haben uns,
wir haben uns gerade gegenseitig gebashed. Aber wenn ich glück habe, kann ich hier noch
in den Tunnel. Guck mal, wir können mal Max rein spawnen. Max Hog. Ja, oder nicht? Wir spawnen
mal den. So, und jetzt habe ich das Problem, wo geht es hier in den Tunnel nochmal rein? Da,
durchs Dach? Ne, durchs Dach kommt man glaube ich nicht. Ah, hier. Hier, nice. Wow, what the?
Geflanked. Alles dead. Ne, einer ist noch. Ist das immer noch, Max? Lass mich rein. Gutschi
Buzz. Player in Combat. Vielleicht, vielleicht dann nicht mal lange. Mal gucken, wie lang das
Player in Combat geht. Oh, jetzt ist er gleich dead. Dead. F. Wie weit, wie weit ist was weg?
Okay, A. Wow, what the? Hä? Alles klar. Du siehst nicht, woran du stirbst. Vielleicht von
einer Granate, vielleicht von irgendeinem Fahrzeug, vielleicht von irgendwas,
das durch die Wall bängt. Okay, stellen wir uns mal Richtung A. In der Hoffnung.
Hinten da irgendwas. Oder, ne, ne, ne, komm. Ich hab gesagt, wir können jetzt von,
was ist in der Mitte? C ist in der Mitte. Ich hab gesagt, wir könnten von hinten da ran.
Ah, komm. Wir gehen jetzt, wir gehen jetzt zu A. Wow. Wie kommt man hier rüber? Das ist
bisschen exposed. Da wär ich gleich gesn... Nice. Sehr gut. Clam. Fall damage. Kann man hier
irgendwie die Dinger hoch klitschen, wie im Battlefield? Oh, nice, nice, nice, fast. Ist
wie im Battlefield 3. Fast wie im Battlefield 3, wollte ich grad sagen. Man kann die Wände
hoch klitschen. Nice. Das mag ich. Das ist schon ein gutes Feature. Gefällt mir schon mal.
Wände klitsch is real. So, jetzt ist hier anscheinend niemand mehr am Start. Es regnet
durch die Dächer. Gut. So wie bei meinem alten Dach. So, ich vermute einfach mal,
das war... Au. Vermute jetzt mal, das war's hier mit A. Wollen wir nachher noch ne Runde
Battlefield 2042 spielen? Ich hab heute nicht allzu viel vor. Wir spielen noch 45 Minuten,
bis der Playtest zu Ende ist. Dann können wir uns noch ne Runde Battlefield 2042 Season 5
geben. War Battlebit das Game, wo man eigene Maps bauen konnte? Ich glaube nicht. Glaube nicht,
dass man hier eigene Maps bauen konnte. So, wir gehen in die Mitte und schießen durch die Fenster.
Ich glaube, das ist besser. Müssen wir da aufpassen, weil ich glaube, die Gegner wollen
das gleiche machen. Okay, nix zu sehen. Wollen wir da mal... Komm, wir werfen jetzt ne Granate rein.
Die, die... Na, geile Medic-Nade. Die mega langsam ist und ewig braucht. Oh. Bis sie smoked,
aber jetzt hat sie gesmoked. Hinter mir. Natürlich. Natürlich. Die einzige Richtung,
aus der wir kommen, da steht natürlich irgendein so ein Dude unten. Jetzt weiß ich aber,
dass er da ist. Jetzt wird er geschreckt gleich. Ja, klar. Fahr vorbei. Ist er noch da? Okay,
äh, wo genau ist... Geht's jetzt runter? Ach, wir sind gar nicht da. Wo ist C? Oh Gott, Leute,
ich... Ah, da. Die Visibility ist teilweise noch ein bisschen unklar. Oh, nee, ich glaube nicht,
dass man hier Maps bauen kann. Wie, das hat er überlebt? MonkaS? Der ist doch bestimmt noch da,
hä? Oder pleaded der gerade? Oh, ich werde geheilt. Wie macht er das? Also irgendwas ist hier noch.
Ist er dead? Ich glaube, der ist dead. Was soll ich holen? Oh. Und wo? Nee, das waren die Leute
oben. Brickfoss. Brickfoss sagt mir auch noch was. Kann ich mich jetzt aber nicht mehr genau
daran erinnern. So. Moin, Phipps. Welches ist denn das nächste hier jetzt? B? A? Ja. Okay,
meine ganzen Dudes rennen Richtung B. Wir rennen auch mal Richtung B. Kek, wait. Wo kam der her?
Der war einfach random mitten auf dem Feld. Wie pinkt man? Hm. Jetzt sind ganz schön viele an B.
Oh. Ah, nee, das ist meiner. Das sind auch meine. Kann man hier drüber? Nice. So, ein paar Punkte
beim Capturen von B. B gecaptured. Okay, und wo geht's? Okay, wo müssen wir jetzt hin? Ah,
wieder C. Da oben ist ein Gegner. Gegners. Okay, scheint der zu sein. Gehen wir mal Richtung C.
Mega. Boah, das Voice-Chat geht mir auf den Sack, Alter. Man hat auch irgendwie Sachen,
die man für Squad-Perks machen kann. Guck mal, ich kann mit 4 irgendwie Minen legen. Mit 1 kann
ich irgendwie, nee, mit, ach nee, mittlere Maustaste muss ich drücken. Was auch immer. Supply,
man kann, man kann Mauern bauen und sowas. Es ist ein bisschen wie dieses Drop-System,
was wir versucht haben in Battlefield 2042, was niemand benutzt. Okay, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen,
da vorne sind einige. Okay, der wird, der wird gerätst jetzt, der Dude. Äh, ich kann nicht.
Nice. Smoke. So, sobald ich Smoke, oh, links ist ein Gegner, links ist ein Gegner. Shit. Oh,
der hat grad 5 Kills auf einmal gekriegt. Dead. Äh, wo war denn das jetzt? Hier? Ich,
ich vermute mal irgendwo hier so in der Ecke. Für mich haben die Maps auch wenig
Wiedererkennungswert. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum die, warum in jedem Game die Russen im
Voice-Chat immer so rumschreien. Weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie, wo, wo, wo ist das System
dahinter? Jawoll, den haben wir. Au! What the hell? What? Oh, shit. Das ist ja echt von allen
Seiten. Doch, spawn, spawn. Oh ja, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Nein, nein, nein, nicht,
nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht Damage bekommen, nicht Damage bekommen. Player
is in combat. Ah, shit, Alter. Okay, rein hier, rein hier, rein hier, rein hier. Player is in
Combat, Combat, Combat. Ah, shit. Der hier, jawoll, zack. C. Also hier ist auf jeden Fall
einiges los. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob man hier irgendwie gescheit flanken kann,
weil ich kann mir die Map einfach nicht merken, wo das eben gewesen ist an der Seite. Und ich
glaube, so ein Melee-Weapon, dass man die Zäune kaputt machen kann, gibt's auch nicht. Da vorne
war es. Bam, next. Wie ist denn der hier hingekommen? Geht's hier irgendwie hoch? Also,
ich habe schon sowas wie einen Grappling-Hook gesehen vorhin an Häuserwändern. Aber ich weiß
nicht, welche Klasse den hat und wie man das benutzt. Der Spawn ist, glaube ich, relativ
ähnlich zu Battlefield. Also so mit Squad-Spawn, Spawn-Beacons und sowas in der Richtung. Okay,
und wer sich jetzt fragt, von wo ich gekillt wurde, man hat keine Ahnung. Ah, aber ich werde
gerätst. Das ist äußerst opog. Links war nur einer. Ja, das ist tatsächlich, denke ich auch.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung von wo. Das ist so ein Game, was man mal zwischendurch eine
Viertelstunde spielen kann oder so. Alter, was war das denn? Ich habe den Chat geöffnet. Ich
konnte mich einfach nicht mehr bewegen. Nice. Also, Y ist nicht hinlegen. Y, merke, Y ist
Chat-Git. Was ist hinlegen überhaupt? Okay, wir dusen hier oben irgendwie am Arsch der Welt mit
dem Auto rum. Gehen wir mal zu B. Was ist hinlegen? V, X, Semi-Auto, Burst, Full-Auto. Also,
wow. Au. What the fuck? Keine Ahnung von wo, aber ich würde mich ja echt gerne hinlegen. Aber ich
weiß den Knopf nicht. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, von wo ich beschossen werde. Deswegen, der ist
ja wieder dead. Herma dead. Irgendwie, von wo, Mann? Mensch, ich muss mal kurz die Katze rauslassen
hier. Ich wollte nur mal kurz in den Playtest reingucken, der noch für eine halbe Stunde läuft.
Das war es. Oh, nice. Ich habe was gekillt. Smoke. Oh Gott, ich muss mich hinlegen. Shit.
Hast du das gehört? Okay, der Dude weiß nicht, dass ich hier bin. Alter,
der hat auch keine Fußschritte und sowas. Okay, rein spawnen an B in der Mitte ist am besten.
Hier ging es, glaube ich, rauf. Oder auch nicht. Da könnte ich, wenn ich Glück habe,
gerätst werden. Gibt es nicht. Wir können an B wieder rein spawnen. Äh, an C. Nee, Moment,
man kann an Spawn-Punkten nicht spawnen. Man kann nur an Playern spawnen. Also,
das an den Flaggen gibt es, wenn ich das richtig sehe, gibt es. Doch. Aber nur,
wenn sie nicht umkämpft sind. Okay. Was eigentlich gar nicht so unsinnig ist. Oh,
shit. Vielleicht sollte man hier auch mehr Burst schießen. Das funktioniert so nicht. Ich muss,
glaube ich, zumal die Gegner auch sehr schnell tot sind. Wahrscheinlich muss man echt mehr Burst.
Burst. Wow, da oben war was. War das meiner? Keine Ahnung. Okay, ich. Au. Von wo? Man weiß es
nicht. Ich sterbe echt zu 90 Prozent an Sachen, wo ich keinen Schimmer habe, wo was ist. Guck,
das hier ist ein Spawn-Beacon. So was haben manchmal die Teams auch. By the way, die Map,
die Map suckt. Ich glaube, es ist auch gleich vorbei. Wie viele Punkte haben wir da noch?
Oh, das dauert ja noch ewig. Nee, nee, nee. Wir spielen mal eine andere Map. Die ist irgendwie
nicht so geil. Da siehst du vor allem vom ganzen Geregnen nichts. Also, ich habe vorhin so eine
Map gespielt in der Stadt. Das war so ein bisschen wüstenmäßig in der Stadt. Also,
nicht die, die wir hier zuerst gespielt haben. Die war ganz gut. Ja, ich weiß,
dass es in Development ist. Und übrigens Legacy Features. Es gibt einen Server-Browser. Hält man
kaum für möglich, aber ist so. Ja, die Map ist es, glaube ich. Die ist ganz gut. Okay,
hier gibt es richtig auf den Sack. Der macht Stelz, gell, da unten? Richtig, richtig,
ein leiser Schleicher. Map mal gucken, wo hier was abgeht. Von wo, von wo? Alter,
ah, da war doch was. Na, gupper. Alter, wie hoch habe ich eigentlich meine Maus-Sensitivität
eingestellt? Das mal kurz. Ich hoffe, der steigt aus, dass ich bei ihm spawnen kann. Jawohl,
nice. Der macht es, der macht es. Easy. Ne, macht er nicht. Warte mal, lass mal kurz gucken. Oh,
die ist sogar ein bisschen zu langsam. Das ist Playtest, jaja. Ab nächster Woche ist es,
glaube ich, Early Access. Okay, wenn ich jetzt... Oh, knapp, knapp, knapp. Shit,
okay. Alter, wie auf einmal 50 Gegner um mich drum herum waren. Ich habe den Flow vom Game noch
nie raus. Bei dem spawnen, please. Jawohl, nice, nice, nice. So, wo sind hier welche? Okay,
ich weiß ja nicht mal, in welche Richtung ich gucke. Ich gucke runter zu C. Da könnten ja
durchaus welche sein. Vielleicht sollte man sich auch mal besser durchs Haus bewegen,
anstatt auf offener Straße. Da drüben waren übrigens jede Menge. Oh, fuck. Das waren zu
viele. Wo sind denn meine Teammates? Alle dead? Nice. Gehen wir zu dem hier an A. Oh,
guck mal, hier kann man durchkrabbeln. Das ist Bock. Oh, der ist schon tot. Ich hätte jetzt
eigentlich gedacht, ich komme hier raus und stehe erstmal 20... Ey, ist der dead? Ja. Okay,
ich würde dich heilen, wenn ich wüsste, wie es geht. Geht das so? Ich weiß nicht,
wie man Leute heilt. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wie heilt man Leute? So? Habt ihr einen Plan?
Wie geht das? Ich habe ernsthaft keinen Plan, wie man Leute heilt. Na, geil. Es ist nicht
sonderlich selbsterklärend auf jeden Fall. Bin ich überhaupt Medic? Ja. Also Leute,
ich hätte euch gehealt, keine Frage. Wenn ich gewusst hätte, wie es geht. Da unten war noch
einer. Aber das sollte mein Team eigentlich care of taken. So, nächste Frage. Okay,
ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wie man heilt. Ich dachte eigentlich, man heilt, indem man sich an
die Gegner stellt. So, ich muss mal kurz gucken jetzt. Keybindings. Sprint, Hovercraft, Jump,
V-Lock, Truck, Blader, Drone, Equipment, Shoot, Fire Mode, Secondary, rechts klicken vielleicht?
Rechts klicken? Rechts klicken mit den Bandages? Könnte das sein? Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Vielleicht muss man rechts klicken. Wie, das war nix? Oh, shit. Dachte ich mir eigentlich,
dass der da rumkommt. Ich meine, ich habe ja auch drauf geschossen. Aber anscheinend nicht gut
genug. Inkombat, Inkombat. Müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ob man mit Secondary Fire die
Leute healen kann. Auf offenem Feld ist hier in der Regel eigentlich immer dead. Was ich gemerkt
habe, die MGs sind teilweise mega stark. Okay, nee, im Auto deployen ist nicht. Vielleicht bei
dem, wenn die nicht mehr inkombat sind. Kommt man raus? Alter, wie einfach mal random drei Gegner
vor mir waren, man. Habt ihr den letzten gesehen? Keck. Oh, shit. Der letzte hat einfach den Kopf
vor mir ins Fadenkreuz gestellt. Bam. Ja, da geht nix, ne? Ich glaube, unter mir ist ein bisschen
was. Ich höre hier sehr viel rumhüpfen. Achtung, mal meine Pistole testen. Legit keine Ahnung,
was mich gerade gekillt hat. Die Luft und mein Squad ist dead. Shit. Warte mal,
bis die aus dem Auto aussteigen wie im Battlefield. Wie sehen eigentlich so die
Punkte gerade aus? Wir kriegen extrem oft den Sack. Aber wir sind gar nicht so schlecht. Okay,
nice. Es gibt bestimmt Leute, ohne Scheiß, die grinden das schon seit Early Access-Beginn
durchgehend, durchgehend, weil ich mir das echt nicht geben könnte. Ich glaube,
man kann mit dem RPG oder sowas die Häuser kaputt machen an diesen Stellen. Ich hab den
ernsthaft gehittet. Aber hier ist Scheiß-Posi. Weg. Weg. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Ich renn
einfach mal. Wahrscheinlich bin ich gleich dead, denn da oben war, glaube ich, auch gerade einer.
Sag mal, das ist Claymore von meinen Dudes, ne? Ist hier oben was? Nee. Aber ich höre unter
mir ganz viel. Ist nur die Frage, sind das meine? Das sind meine. In welche Richtung ist C? Da.
Okay, da sind die Gegner. Also wie das mit dem Häuser kaputt machen geht,
hab ich noch nicht so ganz kapiert. Ey. Oh. Okay, alle dead. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Huch,
knapp. Ich dachte, es gibt Fall Damage und dead. Da will ich so einen Assist. Vielleicht soll ich
mal die anderen Klassen auch ein bisschen ausprobieren. Das Blöde ist bloß, ich meine,
das läuft noch 25 Minuten. Das hat jetzt auch keinen großen Sinn mehr. Ich hab echt Probleme
zu erkennen, wo eigentlich die... Ich gucke in die komplett falsche Richtung. Ich muss dahin.
Ey, das geht so nicht. Ich glaube, wir müssen Richtung A. Oh, Bandaging, Bandaging,
Bandaging, sonst sterbe ich. Kann ich hier rein? Oh, den kann man nur reviven. Ich glaube,
hier sind noch mehr. Ich reloade mal schnell und verstecke mich. Ich weiß immer noch nicht,
wie ich mich hinlege. Den kriege ich nicht. Den kann ich nicht reviven. Jetzt probiere ich's.
Wenn ich mich hinlegen könnte, wäre natürlich deutlich besser. Auf dem Dach, oder? Wo geht...
Wo ist die Treppe? Hier. Ne. Wo ist in diesem Haus die Treppe? Da. Bestimmt alles voller Claymores.
Guck da. Claymorge. Ja, Gott. Also das mag ich gar nicht, dass man überall Claymores
hinstellen kann. Das erinnert mich wie zu besten Zeiten, wo die Leute sich in Battlefield 3 in
irgendwelche Ecken gecampt haben mit der Claymore. Oder gar, erinnert sich noch einer Call of Duty
Free for All Claymore Campen in der Ecke? Das war immer richtiger Abfuck. Jetzt komm,
wir spielen noch mal eine andere Map. Wir haben nur noch 20 Minuten Zeit. Mal gucken,
was es sonst noch so gibt. Ich meine, ich habe das auch teilweise gemacht, aber ich habe die
Claymores allerdings meistens nicht benutzt zum sinnlos in der Ecke schimmeln, sondern gerade in
FFA kommst du halt richtig gut mit dem Silencer so ein paar Map... Oh, die ist neu. Die habe ich
noch nicht gespielt. So ein paar Map-Bereiche kontrollieren und dann hast du halt an einen
von zwei Öffnungen mal eine Claymore gesetzt, dass du halt wusstest, wenn du da nicht hinguckst,
dass keiner von hinten kommt. Aber so das ganze Haus für Claymoren ist schon irgendwie doof.
So, C. Kann man spotten? Nee. Aber man kann Helis hitten. Nehmen wir das jetzt gerade ein? Scheint.
Sollte reichen. Moin, Yoga Kumi. Revive dich. Wahrscheinlich bin ich gleich dead,
weil da einer oben drüber kommt. Oder war er? Ich habe ihn gesehen. Geh mal weg. Head? Header.
Ich gebe dir Header, alter Lahn. Guck mal da. Oh, noch einer. Der will auch Header bekommen.
Aber nicht, aber nicht. Ich pieke nicht an einer gleichen Stelle. Das ist Noob. Noob-Move. Gleiche
Stelle mehrfach pieken. Guck. Schon geht das besser. Einfach nicht gleiche Stelle mehrfach
gepiekt. Overwatch 2 Trailer beim Xbox-Event? Okay. Von wo bitte? Spiel? Hallo? Wo, wo, wo?
Man sieht ja nix. Man weiß ja nicht von wo. Alles klar. Okay, von wo? Von hinten irgendwo,
glaube ich. Okay, da. Irgendwo von da. Ach, da ist er. Da ist er. Guck mal. Arschlinux-Beste.
By the way. Da sind wir uns einig. Arsch by the way. Kann man hier rein spawnen? Jetzt? Bin ich
rausgerupft. Wir gehen wir mal zu C. Was man auf der Map kaum sieht und wenn man es anvisiert,
ganz verschwindet. Rushen wir mal zu C und hoffen, dass uns keiner auf dem Weg wegsnipet. Ich meine,
das ist eine neue Map. Die kenne ich noch nicht. Die sieht tatsächlich mal ganz ansprechend aus.
Okay. Nehmen wir jetzt C gerade wieder ein. Wir sollten aufpassen. Vorhin waren die in dem
Haus hier nebendrin. Okay, daneben ist er. Da sind noch mehr. Rechts war noch einer. Irgendwo,
glaube ich. Nice. Genau da. Den meinte ich. So. Capturen wir mal. C. Jawohl. Okay,
wo geht es weiter? Wie setzt man Marker auf der Map Richtung A, dass ich es finde? Gar nicht.
Gibt keine Marker. Marker sind overrated. Outdated. Cheabated. Neighbors. Wifi. Donated. Bin ich
überhaupt richtig Richtung A? 900 Meter? Nee, im Leben nicht. Wo muss ich denn hin? Doch A. Aber
wenn ich nach A renne, sind das 900 Meter. Das dauert ja ewig, bis ich da bin. Da ist ein Auto.
Please. Mitnehmen. Prager. Ja, das gibt es auf Steam. Battle Bit Remastered. Äh, gibt,
ist aktuell early, ähm, aktuell Playtest. Okay, dead. Playtest. Ist er gecrashed? Noch für ne
halbe Stunde Playtest und dann. Ich hör, ich hör den Heli. Is he dead? Oh, der steigt aus. Der
kriegt jetzt auf den Sack. Da war er doch, oder? Nee. Okay, ich weiß nicht von wo. Und ab nächste
Woche Early Access. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde Abstand davon halten, erstmal irgendwie Early
Access, äh, was zu bezahlen für das Game. Ah, super. Ich weiß nicht, es, es ist nicht die
Grafik. Ich hab nichts gegen solche Grafik, aber insgesamt irgendwie, es, es fühlt sich,
es fühlt sich noch nicht so an, als möchte ich da für jetzt schon was bezahlen. Ich mein,
vielleicht tu ich den auch unrecht und ab nächster Woche gibt's super krasses Update und alles ist
geil so. Kann ja sein. Können wir mal B einnehmen? Ist das, geht das? Oh, der ist dead. Ich weiß
nicht von wo. Ich hau mal ab. Ah, Runde vorbei. Nice. Vielleicht kommt noch, noch ne Map,
wir haben verloren. Aber nur knapp. Sieht aus wie Roblox. Ja, schon ein bisschen. Ja,
war ganz okay. Äh, ja, keine Ahnung. Ich würd mal sagen, letzte Runde,
viertel Stunde geht die, geht das, geht der Playtest noch. Ich guck mir ne Zusammenfassung
von dem, von dem ganzen Xbox. Was ist, wer zeigt denn heute was? Was ist denn das? Xbox,
Bethesda und hast du nicht gesehen? Showcase oder? Ich guck mir danach ne Zusammenfassung an. Diese
ganzen Pressekonferenzen sich anzugucken ist total müßig. Was ist da? Total müßig, weil das
besteht eigentlich nur zu 90 Prozent aus irgendwelchen Füllwörtern und das alles super
excited ist und sowas. Da guck ich mir im Nachhinein lieber die Zusammenfassung an. Das ist die Map,
die ich mein. Die hab ich vorhin gespielt, die war ganz gut. Die ging durchaus klar. Ich mein,
ich sollte vielleicht mal ne andere Klasse spielen, wenn ich keine Ahnung habe. Komm,
wir spielen mal Engineer. Was hat denn was für ein Loadout? Was hat ein Engineer? M4A1. Oder ich
bleib mal bei, bleib mal bei M4A1. Was hat denn der Engineer noch für Secondary? Gibt's da auch
Deathm- Ich glaube, es gibt noch. Hier, Primary Gadget, Miene. Ja, freu ich mich. Secondary Gadget,
okay. Ach, kann ich das bei Medic auch ändern? Primary Gadget, Miene. Ach, deswegen haben die
alle diese dumme Claymore dabei. Oh, das sackt ja mal richtig. Secondary- Moment,
ich hab nen Secondary Gadget, was Medikit ist. So wollen- Keine Smoke, ne Frag nehmen wir mit.
Okay, gut. Okay, Secondary Gadget brauch ich. Alles klar. Deploy. Lass mich noch mal ins Auto
mit rein, please. Sonst ist es so weit. Ne, ist gar nicht so weit. Okay, wie mach ich denn
mein Secondary Gadget? Oder ist Secondary Gadget einfach rechte Maustaste? Was ist da los? So,
und hier hab ich schon einen gesehen mit nem Grappling-Hook, der auf die Häuser rauf konnte.
Das war nice. Da konnte man richtig bashen von oben. Wahrscheinlich ist es der Engineer,
vermute ich jetzt mal. Wissen tue ich's nicht. So, hier müssen wir aufpassen. Jetzt stellt's
schon- What the fuck? Wow, wow, wow, wow. Ich hab so ein bisschen Schiss, hier runter zu retten
gerade. Das ist so Metro-Metrolight. Ja, schlechte Idee gewesen da. Leute, wenn irgendjemand ne Ahnung
hat, wie man sein Secondary Gadget einsetzt- Nice, ich war one-shot- wär ich euch sehr verbunden,
mir das zu sagen. Secondary Gadgets. Okay, Keybindings. Secondary Gadget, Alpha 5. Okay,
man muss 5 drücken. Okay, das muss man auch wissen. Das steht nirgendwo. Guck mal, da ist er auf dem
Dach. Das meinte ich, das ist extrem- Okay, 5 muss ich drücken. Ach, 5 ist ein Medipack. Es steht
einfach nirgendwo. Ist einfach top-top-secret, wie das Medikit funktioniert. 5 muss man drücken. Ja,
meine Güte, meine Güte. So, und jetzt müsste ich nur noch wissen, wie man sich hinlegt. Dann wäre
ich ja glücklich. Geht nicht, geht nicht. Hier durch. Alles dead, ge? Alles weggesprungen. Oh,
Bandage, Bandage. Oh, da oben ist noch ein Gegner. Pistole. Ah, ne, das ist meiner. Ich werde geheilt.
Jawoll. Guck mal, ich kann euch auch heilen. Hier. Levi, komm her. Ich muss euch healen.
Heal, heal, heal. Komm her. Ja, nice. Oh, ich hoffe, das Spiel hat kein Friendly Fire. Von wo
kommt denn das? Von oben? Sehe ich das richtig? Ist da irgendwo oben was? Ne, oder? Oh, der ist
dead. Ich habe so ein bisschen Schiss, hier rauszugehen. Weil sobald da nur mein Kopf raus
guckt, ganz schlechte Idee, hier oben lang zu stelzen. Oh, oh, oh, da ist ein UAV oder
irgendwie. Oh, shit. Das war zu viel. Oh, ich werde gerätst. Massive Pog. Und ich werde geheilt.
Die haben sich aber richtig drauf hier. Poggers. Massive Pog Teammates. Okay, das war es jetzt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass mich hier noch einer holt. Da unten sind nämlich auch noch jede Menge Gegner.
Aber ich glaube, ich kann hier oben rein spawnen. Wo bin ich gerade gestorben? Hier, oder? Ich habe
null Orientierung auf dem Maps. Keck. Wirklich gar kein Plan. Okay, alles in Combat. Der ist
nicht in Combat. Wir capturen. Lege Henne. Ich glaube, man konnte hier irgendwie... Oh, oh,
da war was. Oh, da ist gerade einer ausgestiegen noch. Ich habe keine Muni mehr. Ich verstecke
mich jetzt. Okay. Ist der aufs Dach rauf? Oh, fast Rainbow Six. Nächstes Rainbow Six, Leute.
Oh, schlechte Idee. Oh, alles klar. Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Das war... Da unten unter euch,
Leute. Guck mal, da ist der Schneiber. Schneiber-Dude. Gehen wir zu dem hier. Pass mal auf,
ich heile dich. Komm her. Wenn ich Glück habe... Wenn ich Glück habe, werde ich doch gerätst.
Oh, ich werde gedraggt. Oh, jetzt ist er dead. Jetzt ist er dead. Alles dead. Ich glaube,
man kann das ganz gut spielen, wenn man die Map kennt. Dass du weißt, in welche Ecken die Gegner
gerne schimmeln und wo die Gegner herkommen und sowas. Sie haben gefühlt die gleiche Bullet
Penetration wie in Battlefield 3. Du stehst hintereinander, sprichst in die Richtung,
Bam, dead. Ich laufe mal hier mit dem Sniper. Snipe X. Ne, oder sowas ähnliches. Kann ich
aussprechen. Kann es sein, dass wir alle M-Comps haben? Krass. Wir sind ja richtig gut. Komm,
ich bin Dritter. Was ist denn hier los? Das muss an den Heal Points liegen. Kann man jetzt sagen,
ich will da hin? Ja, tatsächlich. Kann man markern. So, komm her. Nicht campen. YOLO.
Durch hier. So, übliche Sache, was man in Shootern macht, Treppencampen. Ah, das ist meiner. Unter
mir ist einer. Und das ist keiner von mir gewesen. Hä? Ich höre hinter mir einen rumrennen die ganze
Zeit. Das ist nicht, oder ist das mein Teammate aus der ersten Etage? Ne, es war tatsächlich der.
Oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich muss weg. Ich bin raus hier. Da war noch einer. Oder war das ein Gegner? War
das meiner? Das war meiner. Oh, ich werde gehealt. Müssen wir mal ausprüfen, ob ich mich selbst
healen kann. Dead. Oh, hier ist viel los. Da war einer. Die sterben halt auch mega schnell,
gell? Eigentlich musst du nur an irgendeinem Hotspot im Haus sitzen und warten, bis einer
die Straße kreuzt und dann bist du dead. Hier oben sind auch schon wieder Gegner. Okay,
das ist gefühlt durch den Kopf durchgeflogen gerade. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich mich
raustrauen kann. Ich glaube nämlich, sobald ich rausgehe, bin ich auch dead. Aber wenn ich hier
zu lange stehe, wahrscheinlich auch. Ich höre was unter mir. Wusste ich doch. Und ich höre noch
mehr. Von oben, von unten. Wo ist hier gerade was explodiert? Hier nicht. What the? Angeblich
explodiert hinter mir was und ich sehe halt nichts davon. Damit hättet ihr nicht gerechnet. Okay,
okay, okay. Wo? Das sind meine, die ich da die Schritte höre. Rechts ist irgendwas. So,
ich weiß jetzt nicht. Ja, Moment. Von wo? Von wo kommen die denn jetzt von da? Ich glaube,
ich kann jetzt aus dem Haus hier raus. Lass mal auf die Map gucken. Ach, die kommen von da,
weil das da Spawn ist. Ja, sagt es doch einer. Das ist das Spawn. Ja, dann. Kein Wunder. Ja,
das vielleicht. Okay, vielleicht sollten wir aufhören, die Spawn zu rapen. Ist nicht sehr
nett. So, wir gehen zu A. Was ich wie immer nicht auf der Mini-Map gescheit finde. So,
wir gehen hier hin. Auf geht's. Ich weiß nicht, wie man da hinkommt. Aber wir gehen jetzt da hin.
Wir gehen jetzt zu A. Es hört sich permanent an, als wird an mir vorbeigeschossen. Okay. Das ist
halt hier. Das kann man nicht sagen. Okay, das ist halt minimalistische Grafik. Hier ist einfach
nichts. Gar nichts. Und du erkennst es auch nicht mal richtig, dadurch, dass du keinen
gescheiten Schattenwurf hast. Du kennst es auch nicht mal richtig, wo der Tunnel hier irgendwie
übergeht zur Wand und so. Also, ich mag den... Also, wie gesagt, ich habe nichts gegen solche
Grafikstile. Aber hier, die Umsetzung gefällt mir nicht gut. Na klar, es ist ja noch vor Early
Access. Aber so grundlegende Sachen. Und man im Tunnel erkennt, wo das Ende ist. Und beim Sound
hast du halt auch das Problem, du denkst die ganze Zeit, die sind neben dir. Und sind sie halt
einfach gar nicht. Okay, wo geht's denn hier überhaupt lang? Zwei Minuten ist der Playtest
vorbei. Das war's, oder? Oder wird das einfach nur so mal eingeblendet? Weil ich habe überhaupt
keine Ahnung, wie man aus dieser hässlichen U-Bahn rauskommt. Was passiert, wenn du P drückst?
Nichts. Ich glaube... Warte mal. Kann man sich respawnen? Okay, besser. Ich glaube,
nach der Runde ist es vorbei. Dann muss ich mal ganz kurz AFK und dann bin ich gleich wieder da.
Oh nein, ich bin wieder in der U-Bahn. Damit fangen wir jetzt gar nicht an mit dem U-Bahnstelz.
Okay, easy. Server has to be shut down. Okay, GG Eats. Okay, Playtest vorbei. Ist vorbei. Änderer
mal kurz den Titel. Oder ich muss mal ganz kurz AFK. Chat. Eine Runde. AFKlo. Bad Company 2
streamen. Ob es auch irgendwelche aktiven Server gibt. Bleib wieder da. Wieder am Start. So als
Abschied. Wieso? Bad Company 2 wird doch nicht abgeschaltet. Es wird... Was wird denn abgeschaltet?
Bad Company 1 oder sowas? Also sprich alles, wo man irgendwelche Services abschalten kann. Bad
Company 2 auch. Aber Bad Company 2 hat doch self-hosted Services. Das wirst du doch gar
nicht abschalten können. Was wollen die da abschalten? Die paar offiziellen Server oder
den Master Game Browser. Ja, das wird relativ schnell wahrscheinlich von irgendwelchen anderen
übernommen. Da gehe ich mal von aus, dass Bad Company 2 nicht unplayable bleiben wird. Was heute
ansteht, wir haben gerade den Battle.Bit Playtest gemacht und jetzt muss ich mal schnell aufs Klo.
Und nur muss ich den Streamtitel mal halbwegs gescheit machen. WhitePepoHappy. Kannst du es aus
den Stores entfernen? Was meinst du? Ja. Also so nach über zwei Monaten habe ich mich jetzt
halbwegs eingewöhnt. Wann wird ein BC2 abgeschaltet? Hier Alternate Server bla bla. Ah, Ende des Jahres
2023 oder sowas anscheinend. Heute erst meinen YouTube Kanal entdeckt. Pog. Hast du jetzt zwölf
Jahre Content zum Nachgucken? Nee, ganz ehrlich, vieles von meinen ersten Videos ist halt so,
ist Call of Duty Battlefield bezogen. Das ist in der heutigen Zeit jetzt auch nicht
mal wirklich aktuell. Mirrors Edge? Moment, was genau muss an Mirrors Edge shutdown werden? Das
ist doch ein Singleplayer Game. Irgendwelche Rangelisten oder sowas. Ja, ey, ich meine,
zurecht, oder? C++ hat es verdient. So Leute, ich glaube, ich habe Bock noch ein paar Runden
BF2042 zu spielen. Das war mal jetzt. Muss ich da mal kurz ausblenden. EA App öffnen. Also ich
weiß immer nicht, was das liegt und sowas. Wenn man die EA App startet. Zeit fürs Bett? Nee,
so eine 1-2 Stunden habe ich noch Zeit. Okay, wir sind wieder da. Mach wieder an. So, wir
brauchen jetzt einen guten Titel. Für den Stream. Ich würde sagen, Cacklefield 2042.
Cacklefield 2042 Season. Season 5. Irgendeinen Titel brauchen wir. Und da muss ich das Game
noch ändern. Battlefield 2042. Moment Leute, ich habe gerade in Twitch eingegeben 2042 und es
wird ein Spiel vorgeschlagen. Clownfield 2. Moment, das gibt es wirklich? Okay, na was auch immer. So,
dann gucken wir uns noch mal eine Runde Season 5 an. In der Hoffnung, das Game startet gescheit.
Nein, nein, nein, keine komischen EA Sport Games. Hören wir Plus auf. So, und jetzt haben wir wieder
das Problem, dass wahrscheinlich Battlefield jetzt zu laut ist, weil Windows Sound Settings
immer extremes Cack W sind. Nee. Muss ich für jeden Mist Geld ausgeben. So, jetzt ist es bestimmt
viel zu laut gleich. Das Game hat ja keine Musik, also insofern hört man im Menü nicht, ob es zu
laut ist. Nervt nicht. It's Double XP Weekend. Leute, endlich. Ich habe gewartet, endlich zu
Prestigen in 2042. Hat das Game überhaupt sowas wie Prestiges? Weekend bis Mittwoch. Ah ja, komm,
in dem Game darfst du das alles nicht so genau nehmen. Rusch. Let's go. Rusch. Warum hat das
Spiel keine Menü Musik? Das hat einfach nichts irgendwie. Gut, das hat auch keinen Soundtrack.
Musik ist bloated, ja. Spielt das eigentlich noch jemand? Du musst das spielen, immer wenn eine
neue Season rauskommt. Zum Beispiel jetzt. Dann ist es für ein paar Tage oder ein, zwei Wochen ganz
okay. Rest kannst du knicken. Wir haben gleich gewonnen. Okay, nice. Typische Erika Haber Runde.
Alles hockt rum und bewegt sich nicht. Hoffentlich habe ich für diese Waffe bald mal ein gescheites
Visier. Das regt mich auf hier. Jetzt haben wir direkt einen Vergleich hier. Battle Bit vs.
2020. Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow. Ihr bewegt euch eh nicht her. Was ist Battle Bit? Minecraft Battlefield.
Ein Spiel, was ein bisschen wie Battlefield sein will mit Pixel Grafik. Haben wir gespielt,
am Anfang des Streams, irgendwie 45 Minuten Playtest. Ich habe den getroffen. Ich glaube,
wir müssen die Attacker pushen, weil die sich hier nicht bewegen. Kann das sein? Die
moven einfach nicht. Was ist da oben los? Die haben keinen Bock. No move,
kämpke. Ich bin gleich dead. By the way, es war klar, dass mich da irgendwas von der Seite
schneibt. Normalerweise sollte man als Defender... Oh, da kommt ein Tank rein. Was ist hier? Was
ist... Was soll das? Warum fährt da einfach ein Tank in die Base? Wollen die doch noch die
Liegehände machen. Glaube mich aber nicht jetzt. Ne, wollen sie nicht. Ist das... Ah ne,
das ist der... Ich dachte, das ist die Attacker Drohne. Übrigens, da muss man sagen, da war
Bad Company 2 tatsächlich ein bisschen so vor seiner Zeit mit diesen Drohnen und sowas. Hatte
zum damaligen Zeit sonst kein Game und auch in den Nachrichten war das noch nicht so groß.
Okay, ich werde eh wieder geschniped jetzt gleich. Aber was willst du machen? Die Attacker
bewegen sich halt nicht. Wenn sich die Attacker nicht bewegen, muss ich halt versuchen,
irgendwie fortzupuschen. Ah, ich habe vergessen, die neuen Assault Rifles treffen ja nicht mehr
über Range, wenn man nicht tappt. Also muss ich... Die haben gelegt. Ich fasse es nicht.
Die haben gelegt. Ich dachte, ich kann ja noch Shotgun. Okay, nice, nice. Hoffentlich,
hoffentlich ist die Runde jetzt vorbei. Und dann sind wir bei der nächsten. Von Anfang an mit
dabei. Ein Ticket noch, ja. Easy win. Komm, wir gehen mal ins Häuschen hier. Was ist denn das
hier eigentlich? Drei verschiedene Clothes. MWD. Okay, wir haben es. Wir haben es. Hoffentlich
Präge Chat. Präge für gute Map. Präge für gute Map. Es gibt nur eine Map, wo ich Instant Rage
quitte und das ist Hourglass. Wobei, nee, ist Hourglass nicht jetzt überarbeitet? Oder wird
Hourglass mit Season 6 überarbeitet? Ich war eindeutig im geilsten Squad aller Zeiten. Ja,
ganz toll. Next. Aha, sehr gut. Next. Mal gucken, ob ich jetzt endlich ein gescheites Visier für
die R68, R98 oder sowas in der Richtung beigeschaltet habe. Zeigt mal her. Collection.
Welche ist denn das überhaupt? Die hier? Gescheites Visier? Noch nicht. Wobei das Holo... Oh,
geht schon los. Breakaway. Das ist auch nicht meine Map. Wobei sie die bei Rush überarbeitet
haben. Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob die neuen M-Com
Placements jetzt so viel besser sind. Ist es eigentlich noobisch mit der... Was haben wir
denn hier sonst noch zu auswählen? Ist es eigentlich Noob-Style mit der Secondary Shotgun
rumzulaufen? Das machen die coolen Leute nicht, oder? Oh, Defender. Ist eigentlich ganz gut. Wir
haben den letzten Stream hauptsächlich Attacker spielen können, wobei mir in Rush Attacker auch
viel mehr Spaß macht. Nun gut. Let's go. Wir rushen denen einfach mal sinnlos entgegen und sterben
jetzt. Warte mal, wo spawnen die nochmal? Ah, da hinten irgendwo. Come on. Oh, ich spotte mal
ein bisschen sinnlos in Smoke rein. Oh, da kommen sie schon. Lege Hände! Das kriegt ihr doch.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Achtung, Smoke, Smoke. Smoke. Nein, nein, nein. Fuck, Alter. Was ist mein
Smoke hier? Alter, ich bin so planlos gerade, was die Keybindings angeht. Das ist ja echt der
Wahnsinn. Bam! Ah, schön weggetappt. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich da gerade was... Habt ihr
da gerade was mit Rennen sehen? Das erscheint mir ein bisschen in Spawn-Recamper auszuatmen gerade
hier. Okay, nee, macht's nicht. Ich habe nichts gesagt. Nice. Optimum Spawn. Ihr hättet vielleicht
doch nicht so offensiv rumstehen sollen an der Stelle. Gut, Dach. Zack. Wobei, nee, nicht Dach.
Wir gehen nicht aufs Dach, Leute. Wir machen das anders. War hier nicht mal ein Tor? Mal gucken,
ob das noch geht. Mal gucken, ob das noch geht. Das geht nicht, oder? Ich dachte,
ich habe das M-Com gehört gerade. Ich wollte eigentlich gucken, ob das noch funktioniert,
Leute. Achtung. So. Kämpke. Nice, der M-Com-Abkämpfer. Oh, guck mal, da ist schon der Erste hier.
Dead. Ja, komm. Tiagur. Dings. Diffuse mal. Ich passe hier oben auf. Ich habe kein C4.
Ich brauche C4. Ich habe eine Fraggranate dabei und einen Smoke-Launcher. Es ist auch eine sehr
faire Position da oben, ja. Oh, die haben noch 37 Tickets. Wir sollten wirklich einfach ein bisschen
aufpassen. Wir sollten echt ein bisschen chillen am M-Com. Und gut ist, sobald hier was durchkommt,
ist er eh dead. Nein, er ist fast dead. Aber guck mal, den könnt ihr doch retzen, Leute. Oh,
was ist hier? Was ist hier? Was ist hier? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was da war,
aber da war auf jeden Fall was. Oh shit, PPGAM. Ich sage prepare. Leute, prepare for heavy PPGAM.
Shit. Okay, wir müssen aufs Dach kurz. Shit, shit. Da sind bestimmt noch mehr. Okay,
okay. Vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir es noch. Jawoll, Diffuske. Diffuske. Sehr schön. Sehr gut,
sehr gut. Ich kämpf, ich kämpf mir mal kurz hier oben einen drauf ab. Das ist immer sehr beliebt.
Komm, hauen wir mal eine Granate hier in die rechte. Optimum. Hiya Qnade. Es sind nur noch
acht Tickets. Ich bleibe jetzt einfach hier und dann winnen wir easy. Lass mal auf, easy win. Oh,
da kommt, da kommt. Oh, was ist das? Was ist das? Panzer. Pantsman. Pantsman. Oh, gehst du weg?
Weg. Panzer. Dude. Easy. Nice. Superior position, Leute. Einfach unterm Dach gekämpft. Da
guckt niemand hin. Ihr habt es gesehen, ne? Niemand guckt da hin. Ich meine,
wer rechnet auch damit, dass da oben an diesem doofen Pfosten jemand unterm Dach steht?
Bestes Squad. Okay, wir haben gesackt quasi. Ja, Container Field 2042. Oder, oder,
oder Kackle Field. Aber die neue Map, ihr werdet es kaum glauben, Leute. Jetzt,
kack wait. Haltet, haltet euch fest. Die neue Map hat gar nicht so viele Container. Dafür hat sie
leere Bahnwaggons als Containerersatz. Vielleicht haben wir Glück. Prager für die neue Map.
Prager für die neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map. Neue Map.
Äh, was war das jetzt? Ach, das war erst Ende der Runde. Leute, ich frage mich ja ernsthaft,
wie man das früher gemacht hat, als man keine fünf Minuten warten musste zwischen den Runden.
Da konnte man einfach in ein Spiel beitreten und dann war die Runde fertig und dann ging direkt
die nächste Runde los. Ohne, dass du zwischenzeitlich mal kurz aufs Klo gehen kannst und
noch was zum Mittagessen kannst. Es ging einfach weiter direkt. Das dauert hier immer ewig. Runde
vorbei, dann erstmal Minute Outro-Screens und sich aufgeilen an irgendwelchen Kack-Skins und
dann nochmal eine Minute suchen und wenn überhaupt, wenn es mal reicht. Und dann nochmal Pre-Game
Lobby. Das dauert fünf Minuten zwischen den Runden. Das ist total ätzend. Money Fist. Okay,
nice. Hoffentlich Attacker, weil Money Fist habe ich, glaube ich, erst einmal gespielt,
seit den Rush-Anpassungen. Die haben ja die M-Comps umplatziert. Wie ich finde,
nicht zum Besseren. Sie haben nämlich die letzte Base rausgelassen. Die letzte Base,
finde ich, eigentlich mit der Basis oben auf dem Berg, fand ich eigentlich mit am coolsten auf
Money Fist. Jetzt spielst du eigentlich nur die Money Fist-Teile, die langweilig sind. Oh,
schon wieder Defender? Ah, okay. Einmal spielen wir noch Defender und dann leave ich,
wenn wir nicht Attacker sind. Am Anfang, als Rush neu war, hast du immer Defender gespielt,
wenn du die erste Runde Defender warst. Total, wir maintain control. Sag mal,
hat da grad irgendjemand across the map irgendwie Granaten geballert? Oh Gott,
man darf nicht mehr Autofeuer machen mit den Assault Rifles. Sobald man tappt,
geht es gleich viel besser. Wie gefällt dir das Game? Ja, ich würde sagen,
man könnte bald mal so einen Public Play Test machen. Oh, shit. Lass mich in Ruhe,
Leute. Irgendwo da war was hinten. Okay, wir pushen mal kurz rüber. Ich bilde mir ein,
da war was. Nice. In the ass. In the ass over here. Okay, hier ist nichts mehr. Bam. Wie,
was erlauben die sich einfach nebenbei die M-Comps hier zu planten? Oh, oh, oh, direkt Anzeige. Ein
mehr Heal Pen könnten sie einem auch gönnen, oder? Okay, kein Plan, wie man den hitten soll.
Ich campe noch mal ein bisschen hier am Eingang. Vielleicht erwische ich ja noch ein paar. Ha,
Lul. Ja, ganz bestimmt, Game. Ganz bestimmt, Game, war das eben ein Headshot? Okay,
ich meine, ich will mich nicht beschweren, wenn die mir die ganze Zeit reinrennen. Das ist schon
okay. Das ist schon in Ordnung. Ihr wisst aber jetzt, dass ich da bin, oder? Ja, wäre ich jetzt
ein geiler Aimer, wäre ich jetzt so ein geiler Aimer, wie manche CS-Bros, hätte ich den da vorne
easy weggetappt. Aim on point, das sieht nur so aus. Ihr könnt euch wieder für heftigstes PPGA
Aim preparen heute. Mir fehlt einfach komplett die Übung, was Shooter und Battlefield angeht.
Das war Glück. Das sieht nur so aus. Meinst du ernst? Ich wollte eigentlich nachladen. Moin. So,
wie kommen wir denn jetzt hier? Okay, wir verpissen uns jetzt mal ganz schnell. Die
kommen doch bestimmt von da vorne reingestellt gleich. Da sind sie doch schon. Da war doch,
da war doch gerade schon einer. Wusste ich doch. Oh, hier geht's nicht weiter, ne? Ich
habe ein bisschen Schiss. Okay, komm, mach deinen Kopf weg, Alter. Okay, schlechte Idee, Max. Gar
eine schlechte Idee. Vielleicht kriege ich einen Rez. Wenn ich Glück habe, ich liege hier nicht so
weit abseits. Nee, nee, nee. Hier kommt keiner. Release. Wie läuft's? Joa, geht so. Ich habe
die erste Runde. Ah, geil, da ist was. Direkt davor, direkt vor mir. Oh, lege Hände, lege Hände.
Diffuse. Diffuse. Oh, von hier. Da kommen gleich noch mehr, Leute. Das ist meiner. Von wo? Ah,
von da oben. Shit. Gibt es keinen Cooldown zum Respawn? Das ist Battlefield 2042. Was war das
so? Meinst du, die hätten sich für Rush Gedanken gemacht? Nee, das war nicht, das war nicht agil
genug. War nicht, nicht im Scope. Okay, nice. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich muss diffusen. Das
macht sonst keiner. Ja, erster. So mag ich das. So ist das Pog. Oh, das ist eine schlechte Pose.
Jawoll, jawoll. Lass mich diffusen. Diffuske. Diffuske. Ich höre von hinten was. Nee, nix.
Diffuske. Und nicht mehr erster. No. Rentner. Nee, der heißt nicht Rentner. Der heißt Rentner.
Ich habe Rentner gelesen. Ich dachte, er will mich veräppeln. Auf mich trifft das ja auch schon
fast zu. Überlegt euch mal. Ich kann in ungefähr 25 Jahren in Rente gehen. Kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen. Ich werde 39 in ein paar Monaten. Alter, das kommt mir echt nicht so vor. Ich sitze
vor dem Rechner, spiele Battlefield und sage, keck W. Ist Battlefield 2042 jetzt eigentlich
wirklich so viel besser mittlerweile? Naja, okay. Ja, es ist so viel besser, weil es einfach richtig
kacke war, als es rausgekommen ist. Ich würde sagen, es ist jetzt in einem Zustand, dass man es
durchaus Battlefield bezeichnen kann und dass man sich jetzt mal überlegen könnte, demnächst
vielleicht eine Beta zu machen oder sowas. So ein Public Playtest und dann vielleicht so Release
Ende des Jahres anpeilen. Immer noch nicht das Gelbe vom Ei. Nee. Nee, immer noch nicht das Gelbe
vom Ei. Und ich glaube auch, ehrlich gesagt wird das nie das Gelbe vom Ei. Oh, wir haben ein
gescheites Visier unlockt. Für das Ding. Was jetzt? Okay, okay. Die schlechteste Map im ganzen
Game. Mal gucken, ob sie die reworked haben. Ich bilde mir einen, die haben sie reworked. Ich weiß
bloß nicht, ob es diesen Patch schon war oder der nächste Patch ist reworked. Defender, Defender
sackt ja mal. Sag mal, darf ich noch was anderes spielen als Defender? Gibt es wieder den Bug,
dass man die Seiten nicht wechselt? Das haben die doch schon lange behoben und es sieht auch
nicht so aus, als wäre es eine andere. Nee, das ist nicht reworked, oder? Das ist immer noch das
Gleiche. Vielleicht wird das nächste Battlefield ja besser. Besser ja, aber ob sie jemals wieder
den Spirit einfangen? Ich glaube es nicht. 3D-Spotting ist da einfach okay. Massive Aim,
alter Leute. Krasses Aim aller Zeiten. Ich habe mich an das andere Visier schon gewöhnt,
obwohl das so doof ist. Jetzt habe ich wieder Probleme mit dem Red Dot. Oh nice, guck mal,
es gibt Muni. Das Game sieht so platt aus, ja korrekt. Sieht nicht nur so aus,
spielt sich auch so. Da war kein einziger Hit dabei. Seriously? Da kommt was hier. Alter,
ich war hinter dem Schild, man. Okay, das Schild war halt einfach nur dünnes Wellblech. Also wenn
ich nächste Runde wieder Defender bin, dann gehe ich raus. Scheint mir nicht so ganz fair
balanced zu sein gerade. Oh, da hinten fällt was um. Ey, ey, lass mich in Ruhe. Einfach
immer 3D-Spots spammen. Auf die Range ist es nicht ausgelegt, ne? Gehen wir mal kurz checken,
was da drüben abgeht. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Lass mich in Ruhe. Hier ist
eigentlich eine ganz gute Posi. Weiß jetzt eigentlich jemand von euch, ob die Überarbeitung
schon diesen Patch war von Our Class oder nicht? Wisst ihr noch, wie sie am Anfang von Battlefield
4 so auf Realismus gemacht haben? So nach dem Motto, ein Magazin weggeworfen, 30 Schuss weg
und sowas, selbst wenn man nur eine Sache rausgeballert hat. Das haben sie ganz schnell
wieder aufgegeben. Ich glaube, es hat es noch nicht mal aus der Battlefield 4 Beta rausgeschafft.
Teams wechseln. Hey, das, das, mittlerweile kannst du nicht Teams wechseln, du kannst
immerhin Squads wechseln. Das ist jetzt als Legacy-Feature wieder mit drin, seit diesem
Patch. Squad wechseln. Au. Ey, lass mich in Ruhe. So, Mr. Pantsman. Sag mal, what the hell?
Wollt ihr mir ernsthaft erzählen, das hat nicht gehittet gerade? Das ist doch, das ist einfach
straight fünfmal durchgeflogen. Au. Voll in den Panzer rein. Ja, ey, ich schieße extra schon
sehr sparsam mit Tabs wegen dem Assault-Rifle-Nerf. Hier ist eine Top-Posi. Sobald die an A rangehen,
werden sie gebashed. Ich sehe nichts, Kollege. Ah, ich hole dich, ist gut. Oh, Panzer, Panzer,
Panzer, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer. Kann man hier hoch? Ne. Okay, der Panzer macht uns jetzt ein bisschen
das Leben schwer, weil niemand A sieht. Oh, oh, oh, oh, Panzer, nein, nein, nein. Okay,
ich renne jetzt einfach an den Panzer ran, dann checkt er es nicht. Doch, er hat es gecheckt.
Oh ne, die Legehenne ist aktiv, Leute. Legehenne active. Ich camp jetzt einfach an B. Ich camp
jetzt einfach an B, weil das ist easy win, solange die B nicht bekommen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, wo man hier am besten abschimmeln kann. Hier, hier ist eine gute Schimmel-Posi. Top,
Top-Schimmler-EU. Weil sobald das hochfliegt, haben die noch zwei Tickets und wir haben eins. Ah,
wir defusen sogar. Guck mal. Ne. Okay, ein Ticket noch, win. So, und wenn ich jetzt wieder Defender
bin, dann gehe ich raus. Radiant Tracer, danke schön für den Sub. Outstanding Performance.
Most Revive. Outstanding Performance. Was kommt als nächstes? Most Kill. Outstanding
Performance. Ich habe keine Outstanding Performance und mein Squad hat gesagt. Na
gut, okay. Ja, mein Squad sagt aber die letzten Runden schon immer. Was ist mit denen los,
Alter? Drei, sieben, vier, sieben. Und vor allem als Engineer, wo wir halt, na doch,
Anti-Tank ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Man kann sagen, wo wir halt keine Fahrzeuge haben. So,
continue. Chat, während wir aufs Game warten, was wollen wir als nächstes machen? Stream-Themen.
Ich lasse euch mal ein paar Sachen zur Auswahl. Oh, neue Map. Pog. Ich lasse euch mal ein paar
Sachen zur Auswahl. Avalonia. Also, was wir uns Technik-Strelz-Kram angucken wollen. Avalonia
UI mal angucken. PHP mal wieder angucken. Oder. Und sonst noch schönes. Ich weiß auch immer,
warum Poggers hier drin steht. Oder Neo-Vim. Die drei Sachen könnt ihr euch aussuchen. Laravel
mit PHP. Das wird was. Oh, wir sind Attacker. Nice. Jetzt geht's rein hier. Was passiert im
Hanzo-Nerv? Ich kenne Hanzo nur noch zu der Zeit, wo er noch Scatter-Arrow hatte. Nee, danach auch
noch. Scatter. Simple Geometry. Scatter. Scatter. Okay, der ist dead. So, ich habe, ich habe, glaube
ich, Attacker über die Seite noch nie gespielt. Schauen wir mal. Ey, Schneiber-Dude, weg mit dir.
What the? Was ist mit euch falsch? Legt einfach in die Ecke. Okay, ich weiß nicht, woher. PPGaim
of Doom. Ich muss mich, muss mich dran gewöhnen. Man muss tappen. Man muss tappen. Max, du musst
tappen mit den Assault Rifles. Und das ist zu schnell getappt. Hätte ich mal ein bisschen ordentlich,
hätte ich das mal ordentlich gemacht. Egal, kann nicht immer klappen. Okay, jetzt reicht's,
Alter. Jetzt werde ich gepusht. Puschke. Shit. Hey, oh, der hat auch noch die SMG am Start
gehabt. Oh nein, ein Räts. Jetzt mal auf Shotgun-Dude. Bam. Fuck, mein Typ war davor.
Scheiße, man. Kein Diablo 4 Quatsch mit so... Dankeschön, Philips. Oh, nice, Doppelkill für
ihn. Kein Diablo 4 Kreiselcrime. Ich habe es noch nicht mal gekauft bis jetzt. Jetzt halten sie
uns aber echt ganz gut hier zurück. Ich habe es noch nicht gekauft. Blizzard hat mich so abgefuckt
die letzten Jahre über. Ich weiß echt nicht, ob ich mir das geben soll. Da sind doch Gegner,
oder? Hier, da, im Busch, im Busch. Im Busch sind sie. Hier. Irgendwo da. Eine Güte, ey. Das
tue ich mir aber gerade schwer mit dem Ding. Erste Runde, habt ihr mich noch gelobt. Aim on
Point, habe ich gesagt, Leute. Das sieht nur so aus. Ey, Mann, von wo? Ich habe keinen Plan.
Bestimmt auf dem Dach. Bestimmt, bestimmt Dach. Oh, da ist einer. Achtung. Das hast du dir so
gedacht, ne? Das hast du dir so gedacht. Achtung, YOLO, YOLO, YOLO, YOLO. Alter, ich muss tappen
mit diesen dummen Assault Rifles. Selbst wenn fünf Gegner sind. Ich darf kein Dauerfeuer machen. Da
muss ich mich wirklich dran gewöhnen. Wenn ich Dauerfeuer mache, dann sieht das zwar so
aus, als bin ich drauf, aber ich bin nicht drauf. Shit. Na gut, man kann es ja mal probieren.
Ja, richtig Noob-Style war das. Ultra-Noob. Da hinten ist doch noch mehr. Da ist noch mehr,
da ist noch mehr, da ist noch mehr, da ist noch viel mehr. Alter, wie viele waren denn auf dem
Dach, Mann? Das hat ja gar nicht mehr aufgehört. Unendlicher Respawn. Was soll ich denn noch machen?
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice. Exzellenter Spawnpunkt. Exquisite. Okay, wir machen das
gleiche wieder. Die sind bestimmt noch da, Leute. Jetzt ist... Ich... Tappen, Max. Tappen,
tappen, tappen. Okay, hier kommt man nicht lang, oder? Ne. Michael50Billion, schön, dass du wieder am
Start bist. Ich kann gerade nicht in den Chat gucken. Ich habe nur gesehen, dass da ein Nightbot
irgendwas an dich geschrieben hat. Shit. Hier kommen wir nicht lang. Chatgist. Vielleicht,
vielleicht können wir hier ein bisschen headglitchen. Bisschen rum headglitchen, ey. Okay,
das wird schwierig. Das wird schwierig. Ah. Shit, Grappling-Hook. Max. Ich glaube,
der ist dead. Wo ist noch mehr? Da oben war doch... Da ist doch noch was. Da ist doch jede Menge.
Rechts kommt was. Okay, Böhnig ganz sicher von wo. Oh, hier ist viel. Hier ist viel los. Hier ist
richtig viel los. Da geht noch eine Granate da hinten in die Ecke. Okay, gut. Jawohl, jawohl,
jawohl. Okay, wir gehen einfach hier oben... Ah, Mann. Also der Grappling-Hook spackt gerade
übelst rum. Legehenne, Legehenne. Exklusive High-IQ-Legehenne. Oh, da oben. Da oben. Habt
ihr ihn gesehen? Ich habe ihn gesehen. Easy win. Pog. MTA21, neue Meta. Glaubt mir. Soll ich
mal ausprobieren? Ich habe jetzt ja eh mehr oder weniger alles freigespielt für die Waffe,
was ich brauche. Ja, können wir mal ausprobieren. Probiere ich die nächste Runde aus. MTA21.
Machen wir. Let's go. Mit den 2042-Aufsätzen. Und mit welchen? Welche Aufsätze empfiehlt mir
der High-IQ-Chatter? Also MTA. Habe ich die überhaupt unlocked? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ja, close. Collection. Hat da gerade irgendeiner geredet? Hat das Game mittlerweile einen
Voice-Chat, Leute? Anscheinend. Oh, nochmal die? Okay. Leute, ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich muss
mal gucken, dass Voice-Chat aus ist. Nicht, dass ich denen die ganze Zeit hier das Ohr ablabere.
Ah ne, hier. Collection. MTA. Unlocked. Habe ich ja nichts für. Okay. Können wir spielen? Options.
Sound. Wo stellt man denn hier überhaupt die? Hat das Spiel überhaupt mittlerweile einen
Voice-Chat? Anscheinend. Untermenü Sound. Aber wo? Untermenü von Sound. Ich sehe es nicht.
Ach, Alter, die Menüs von diesem Spiel sind so kacke, Alter. Okay, es ist eh push-to-talk.
Ach, wir sind auch wieder Attacker. Nice. Ah, fuck, falsche Waffe. Ich wollte die MTA auswählen.
Ich erinnere mich gleich mal dran. Gleich, gleich. MTA. PPGM. Lege Hände. Shit, ich wusste, dass der da steht.
Der Medi-chan ist da. Der kriegt von mir eine Runde. Es ist immerhin Medi-chan. Weebs United.
Okay, welche Waffe brauchen wir hier? MTA. Wo ist denn das Ding überhaupt? MTA21. Okay, let's go.
Let's go. Schalldämpfer? Ohne Schalldämpfer? Was sagt die HiAQ-Experte? Was sagen die Chat-Experten?
Okay. Tab schießen. M416. Die habe ich letzten Stream die ganze Zeit gespielt. Okay. Lege Hände.
Lege Hände. Oh, da kommt gleich was. Da kommt gleich was. Alter, ich bin schon weggerannt vor der Kackgranate, Alter.
Leute, ihr müsst einfach nur auf B drauf schießen. Einfach nur B. Du brauchst die Aufsätze auf kleine und mittlere Entfernung.
Komm, rückst du raus? Gucken wir mal. Erstmal muss ich die Aufsätze anlocken. Lass meine Legehände in Ruhe. Nice.
Legehände. Erfolgreich. Boris. Hat er auf den Sack gekriegt. Wo ist der Schneiber-Dude da hinten? Schneiber-Mann.
Äh. Nope. Ja, als Attacker sollte man nicht so unsinnig Tickets wasten. Wir hätten noch nicht mal...
Oh, Moment. Wir haben noch A noch nicht mal. Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde. Lul. Ich dachte, wir haben gerade...
Gleich, gleich geht die Map auf. Aber wir haben noch nicht mal A. Wir haben nur noch die Hälfte der Tickets.
Ne, ne, so geht das ja nicht. Volle, volle, volle, volle, volle. Rusch. Rusch, rusch, rusch.
Okay. Oh, die Waffe. Da muss ich mich erstmal dran gewöhnen. Okay, das ist komplett anders spielt sich das, als das, was ich davor hatte.
Massive PPGaimt. Ja, aber krassestes PPGaim ever. Aber gut, ich meine, es hat funktioniert.
Okay, nix zu sehen. Hier, du kriegst noch eine Granate da. Genau. Perfekt. Ich hab die Map noch nicht durchschaut.
Okay, dead. Ja, der ist dead. Okay. Charlie Mike. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, was das heißen soll.
Okay. Oh, wir sind schnell. Wir sind schnell. Massive. Fastge sind wir. Extremly fastge.
Oh, ganz blöde Idee, Max. Ganz blöde Idee. Du hast keinen Schalldämpfer. Au. Du hast keinen Schalldämpfer mehr, Max.
Max, du hast keinen Schalldämpfer mehr.
High IQ Play. High IQ Play. Gibt's nix. Das war gut. Das nicht. Aber das war next level gedacht um die Ecke.
Da drüber zu Crapling hucken. Okay. Spielt man das Ding später mit Schalldämpfer oder nicht?
Ich brauch das Ding mit Schalldämpfer jetzt. Sonst wird das nix. Ich brauch meinen Schalldämpfer.
Sonst sehen die die ganze Zeit, wo ich bin. Wow. Okay, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Unter mir geht die Hölle ab gerade. Ich seh keine Gegner. Nice. Den haben wir. Shit. Von der Seite.
Max, kannst du bitte bei DICE arbeiten und ein richtiges Battlefield raushauen? Danke.
Ich würde nicht bei DICE arbeiten. Ich würde DICE aber kostenlos konsulten, ja.
Hat er sich gerade selbst gekillt? Das Problem ist, die wollen kein Feedback.
Fuck, jetzt haben uns Gegner... Die wollen kein Feedback. Die hätten so viel Feedback haben können die letzten Jahre über und die wollten davon nix.
Du machst doch Programmiershit. Ja, aber das ist was anderes. Also ich hab von Spieleentwicklung ja keine Ahnung.
Ah, fuck. Ach, das war der andere auch noch. Wollte grad sagen, wie kann der Typ schon schießen?
Okay, Fruitsalat geht ab. Der ist Pog. Der Fruitsalat.
Hier, PPGAim. Exzellent, PPGAim. Okay, wir müssen das anders machen. Wir haben nur noch 34 Tickets und kommen irgendwie nicht da ran.
Wir müssen jetzt flanken. Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie da außen rum, sodass sie es nicht sehen, sodass sie mich nicht spotten.
Und jetzt muss ich da unten rein und dann muss mein Team bei mir nachspawnen und dann ist das extrem...
Shit, shit, shit. Wir haben ihn nicht gesehen. Was liegt der Typ auch da in der Ecke, wo ihn keiner sieht, man?
Oh, der sieht ihn auch nicht. Guck mal, der sieht ihn einfach nicht. Der sieht ihn einfach nicht.
Okay, rein hier. Nice.
Ich hol dich. Okay, lege Hände, protecten. Lege Hände, protect.
Shit, wieder veraimt. Vielleicht kriege ich noch ein Reds, wenn ich Glück habe.
Shit. Kriege ich noch einen? Kriege ich noch einen? Kriegt ihr noch einen raus? Leute, beeilt euch.
Okay, ich muss respawnen. Respawnen und in Hoffnung, dass mein Team noch da ist. Jawohl, jawohl, hier, Kollege.
Warum kann ich nicht bei dir spawnen? Was ist das hier? Von hinten. Hier hinten war doch gerade noch was.
Alter, in jeder Ecke. Schlimm.
Okay, und jetzt High IQ plays. Man sieht ganz fairer halber da oben den Typ schon.
Schlechte Idee, Max. Schlechte Idee.
Da oben sind sie nämlich schon.
Ah, da war er auch schon.
Headglitchen eine Runde. Eine Runde Headglitchen, please.
War nur noch zu zweit. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob da einer ist. Ich glaube nicht.
Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts.
Ey, es ist in Battlefield immer der, den du nicht siehst. Immer den du nicht siehst.
Du guckst hin und denkst, ah, jetzt habe ich sie. Bam, bam, bam. Und dann kommt irgendein Typ von der Seite und stellst dich weg.
So ist es halt.
Auf Spritze in Porpoise weiter geht's.
Die sterben hier alle gerade.
Warte mal, pass mal auf. Wir müssen da hoch.
Ah, Gott. Wenn das nicht richtig funktioniert, man.
Wait a minute. Sind die alle dead?
Ah, Mist. Okay.
So, jetzt müssen wir irgendwelche High IQ Flanks machen.
Der läuft gut. Der läuft gut. Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Jetzt dürfen wir uns nur hier nicht abfarmen lassen. Oh, diffuse, gell?
Jetzt dürfen wir uns hier nur nicht abfarmen lassen.
Hallo. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Die haben es auf uns abgesehen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher von wo.
Ah, nee. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht.
Oh, da ist viel. Okay, wir müssen da... Fuck, fuck, fuck. Lass mich in Ruhe. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Wir müssen hier hoch.
Ey, ist nichts. Okay.
Shit.
Hier kann ich nicht vor.
Ja, du musst da nicht hinpingen. Wie verrückt.
Ich weiß, dass da was geht.
Okay, jetzt.
Na gut. Jetzt bin ich auf einmal in drei Gegnern. Das war blöd.
Okay, wie viel... Alter, nice, nice, nice. Legehennen. Richtig gute Legehennen.
Richtig High IQ.
High IQ Legestells.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Ich bin unschlüssig, wie...
Hinlegen.
Hinlegen. Da sehen die mich nicht.
High IQ Movement Placement.
GG Eats.
Bisschen, bisschen Toxic Chat muss sein.
Wie fandest du Battle.Bit?
Eigentlich eine recht gute Runde hier gerade.
Mir hat oder nach wie vor mir gefällt
die Umsetzung dieses Grafikstils in Battle.Bit nicht.
Es heißt ja nicht, wenn jemand... Also es heißt ja nicht,
dass was komplett detailarm sein muss, nur weil es so einen
minimalistischen Pixel-Grafikstil benutzt.
Ist es aber.
Und ich finde auch die Maps und auch Beleuchtung und alles,
das muss ja nicht schlecht sein. Man sieht ja in Minecraft,
dass das durchaus funktionieren kann.
Es ist aber halt noch nicht mehr Early Access.
Vielleicht kommt ja noch ein richtig cooler Patch.
Aber das ist tatsächlich so mein größter Kritikpunkt.
Und dass ich halt alles noch total unfertig anfühle.
Aber das ist okay.
Dafür ist es ja letztendlich auch da, getestet zu werden.
Aber der Grafikstil, ich glaube, der bleibt halt so.
Und ich finde die Umsetzung dieses Grafikstils nicht gut gemacht.
Ja, Early Access.
Wir haben vorhin den Final Playtest gespielt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass zwischen heute und dem Early Access Start
sich jetzt noch so viel ändern wird.
Oder die haben halt einen riesen Patch,
der dann auch gleich rauskommt.
So, also was für...
Moment, 120 Kills.
Okay, das dauert noch ein bisschen,
bis ich das unlockt habe.
Okay, was brauche ich denn für das Ding?
Wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich den hier.
Und...
So.
Okay.
Und...
Suppressed Sound, Effective Range.
Nosher Kennels!
Oh, ewig nicht gespielt.
Nosher Kennels, Rush, da habe ich jetzt eine Runde Bock drauf.
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass sie die M-Complacements
hier auch überarbeitet haben,
weil die waren eigentlich ganz okay.
Prägel.
Chat, eine Runde Prägel für mich.
Hoffentlich sind wir Attacker.
Okay, komm, wir spielen noch ein paar Sachen für die MTAR frei.
Oder...
Ja, wir sind Defender.
Naja.
Ja, du bist im Gegnerteam.
Warte mal, ich switch kurz rüber ins Gegnerteam.
Ah, das geht ja nicht.
Ich vergaß, Legacy Feature.
Wir können...
Habe ich dich in...
Wie heißt es jetzt?
Habe ich dich in der EA-App?
Da können wir einfach eine Crew machen
und du kannst bei mir rein.
Schick mal deinen...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da Leute addet.
Schick mal deinen Game Attack
Die Leute droppen halt von dem Heli hier gleich raus.
Den muss man im Auge behalten,
sonst ist man direkt dead.
Ja, aber das ist doch nicht alles, oder?
Da kommen doch immer noch irgendwelche Nummern hintendran.
Droppt da keiner raus?
Au!
Okay, wo kommen sie jetzt?
Ey, die fahren ja ganz außenrum, man.
Guckt euch, guckt euch die Heli-Pegas an da hinten.
Wo stelzen die sich denn lang?
Ich dachte, das sind Vögel.
Hast du mir Freundesanfragen geschickt? Nice.
Ich nehme gleich an.
Übrigens, ich habe noch nicht einen Gegner gesehen.
Die snipen nur oder fliegen Heli?
Die haben gar keinen Bock.
Die haben überhaupt keinen Bock mehr zu attacken gerade.
Geht hier was?
Ist da was?
Ich höre was.
Ja, ja, definitiv ist da was.
Okay.
Ich höre was.
Ja, ja, definitiv ist da was.
Oh, shit.
Ja, super.
Da ist er, da ist er.
Hätte ich mal nicht versucht zu retzen.
Warte mal, kann ich das jetzt nicht gerade annehmen, EA-App?
Ähm, nice.
Ich mach gleich, ich mach gleich group nach der Runde.
So viele Browser-Tabs, so muss das sein.
Oh, nee.
Dachcampers.
Da sind noch welche oben.
So kommt man da nicht rauf.
Ist der dead?
Ich glaub, der ist, nee, der lebt noch.
Ey, ja, Leute, was soll ich machen?
Soll ich die Tabs zumachen einfach?
Und dann, dann hab ich, dann weiß ich ja nicht mal, was ich angucken wollte.
Okay, die Nosha-Kennels-Runde ist ein bisschen lame.
Schneiber-Dudes.
Mal hören, ob ich irgendwas höre.
Nö.
Wo sind die denn?
Die bewegen sich nicht.
So, die haben keinen Bock.
Die, die, die moven, die moven einfach gar nicht.
Bäm.
Spritze den Arsch.
Ja, das ist egal, einfach B halten.
A ist eh schwierig.
Oh, wir haben auch noch Diffuse.
Pog.
Extrem die Pog.
Ich mach einfach gar nichts.
Ich bleib einfach an A, an B stehen.
Wir haben es in 20, wir haben es ja in 20.
20 Tickets.
Dann mach ich Krupp in 20.
Ja, nix da.
Die Gegner haben einfach keinen Bock.
Da oben auf dem Dach ist einer, aber gut, mein
Kollege auf dem Dach sitzen,
sichert die halt nicht.
Das M kommt, gell?
Das bringt dir halt nix, da auf dem Dach zu sitzen mit deiner Kack-Sniper.
Drei Tickets, wir haben gewonnen.
Das war's.
Ja, nice.
Okay, ich invite dich.
Wenn ich checke, wie das geht, mach ich das gleich.
Moment.
Norsha Canals spawnt keine neuen Boote.
Ihr müsst schwimmen?
Oh Gott, aber kriegen die irgendwas gebacken?
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass es schwierig zu fixen wäre.
Da sollen sie die Leute halt nicht auf Flugzeugträger spawnen lassen,
sondern direkt an der Küste, wenn sie es mit den Booten nicht hinbekommen.
Dice in 20...
Dice in 2023.
2023, null.
Continue, continue.
Wie macht man eine Gruppe über dieses hässliche Menü in Battlefield 2042?
Wie funzt das?
So.
Nee.
Machen wir mal aus.
Social.
Äh.
Bist du Chris, the Gamer LP?
Okay.
Nice.
Bist du jetzt in der Party drin?
Man sieht das ja irgendwie nicht so richtig.
XXHD.
Ey, du musst aus der Queue raus.
Sonst wird das nicht...
Du kannst mich auch inviten, falls das geht.
Dann kann ich dir nachjoinen.
Äh.
Ah nee, da ist er.
Okay.
Rusch.
Ja, hier sieht man sie in der Lobby.
Das stimmt.
Mal kurz hier über meine...
Heimautomatisierung Licht einschalten.
Ja, viel besser.
Kaleidoskop.
Ich würde jetzt ja eigentlich sagen, ich mag die Map nicht,
aber das müsste ich dann zu mehr oder weniger jeder Map sagen,
was auch irgendwie ein bisschen doof ist,
wenn ich zum Anfang von jeder Runde sage, ich mag die Map nicht.
Was?
Mitbekommen.
Habt das den...
Habt das den über EA Creator Network geschrieben?
Dice hat das gelesen, aber ignoriert.
Was hast du denen geschrieben?
Dass es mit dem Joinen nicht geht oder...
Dass es da Probleme gibt mit dem Lobby-System oder was meinst du?
Ja, also es wundert mich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe eh den Eindruck,
die haben die letzten Jahre über einfach alles ignoriert.
Anders kann ich mir das Ergebnis nicht erklären,
was Battlefield 2042 ist.
Die haben sich gedacht, die Leute haben nur darauf gewartet,
so ein Game wie Battlefield 2042 zu spielen.
Das sagt doch alles aus über die Leute, die noch da sind.
Ach, das Problem mit den Booten also.
Und die waren ja wirklich davon überzeugt.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
wie die zum Releasetag geschrieben haben,
so nach dem Motto
Favorite Games 2021, Battlefield 2042,
I'm really proud of this game und sowas.
Schön gemacht, danke fürs Einsmoken.
Ich... Achtung, das ist so risky.
Was? Warum wurde mein Desktop abgebrochen?
Fuck it! Warum ist das Game so verbuggt?
Warum wurde mein Desktop gerade abgebrochen?
Ich habe die Taste ein...
Ich habe nichts...
Ich habe durchgedrückt die ganze Zeit.
Was ist das?
Lag. Na geil.
Beste.
Ich habe extra so einen YOLO-Disarm gemacht,
weil ich dachte, ah, die gucken noch nicht.
Das geht bestimmt durch.
Nope.
GG, guys.
So macht's Spaß.
Okay, die erste Base hier ist aber auch eh abfucked.
Guck mal, hier kannst du...
Best Game Ever.
Ich glaube, wir sind ziemlich in der Ecke.
Bam.
Location revealed, location revealed.
Warum darf ich da eigentlich nicht mehr rausrennen?
Ich bin doch schon gespawnt, bevor das M-Combat war.
Das hier ist jetzt halt eine mega mieße Position.
Soll ich jetzt hinter einem LKW campen,
bis die reinkommen?
Großer, geiler LKW-Camper.
Wow, was ist mit dem los?
Hat er sich gerade selbst überfahren?
Hat er sich gerade überfahren beim Aussteigen?
Ich sehe nichts.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Ah, Gott, Alter.
Okay, jetzt aber.
Pfeilfelder-Defense ist angesagt.
Jetzt habe ich wenigstens einen, der mich carriegen kann.
Das ist gut, das mag ich. Easy.
By the way, ich kann euch mal die übelste OP-Position zeigen auf der Map.
Aber erstmal versuche ich ein bisschen draußen zu defenden.
Okay, das Ding ist auf Range, mega suckig.
Guckt mal, ich zeige euch mal die krasseste Position ever.
Hier, Leute.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich zeige es euch gleich noch.
Das wusste der, dass ich da hochkomme.
Ja, klar.
Also, also, okay, okay.
Beste Position.
Ich habe es gerade ein bisschen abgefuckt, ja.
Ähm, äh, wo bin ich denn überhaupt?
Ah, Gott, Alter, es geht, geht ja gar nichts.
Aber der Chris macht es, easy.
Oh, oder auch nicht.
Oh, oh.
A dead girl.
Okay, jetzt, ich zeige euch gleich die OP-Position.
Oh, okay.
Alter, wo sind wir denn hier?
Das ist, also, ich mag die Waffe nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob das neue Meta wird.
Also, man kann,
eigentlich,
man kann über die Türen springen
und von oben alles wegrotzen, was da durchkommt.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Hätte ich das jetzt gemacht, wäre vielleicht was gebracht, ja.
Man kann sich so oben auf den Rand von den Eingangstüren stellen
mit dem Grappling-Hook.
Ja, vielleicht muss man einfach nur ein paar Sachen anlocken.
What?
Wie, wie haben die denn jetzt schon gearmt?
Was ist denn das?
What?
Wie soll denn das gehen?
Ist hier überhaupt ein Fahrstuhl, wie man hochkommt?
Hier, ne?
Die haben schon gearmt?
Sind die mit dem Heli abgesprungen?
Wie zum Teufel sind die instant zum M-Com gekommen?
Die...
Hä?
Das ist gutes Map-Design, auf jeden Fall.
Die Grenze ist aufgegangen und es war instant gelegt.
Seilrutschen.
Die haben aber dann auf jeden Fall...
Die sind schon quasi rübergeslided an dieser Rutsche,
während es noch nicht offen war.
Und dann ist es quasi aufgegangen und sie waren schon drüben
und waren halt quasi kurz zwei Sekunden vor Tod und sowas.
Ich bin oben gespawnt und hier runtergehüpft,
weil die B halt noch nicht weg war.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und dann ist es quasi aufgegangen.
So, hab ich irgendwas unlockt für das Ding?
Irgendwas Scheiß?
Übrigens, wisst ihr eigentlich,
Battlefield 2042 hat RGB-Unterstützung für meine Tastatur.
Während das Spiel lädt,
flackert meine Tastatur RGB-mäßig so im Battlefield-Style.
Und nein, das ist kein Bug.
Das ist wirklich RGB-Unterstützung in dieser komischen Logitech-Software.
Noch nix, ne?
Caspian Border.
Das...
kann auch kacke werden.
Kommt drauf an.
Äh...
Äh, warum?
Doch kein Caspian Border anscheinend.
Bei der Maus? Nee, meine Maus macht nix, die Tastatur.
Doch jetzt Caspian Border?
Ja, was denn nu?
Pipega-Kram.
Okay, komm, machen wir mal was Sinnvolles.
Wir haben eine M416.
Gib ihm.
Locked in for deployment.
Suppressor,
Koder-Visier,
Shotgun-Attachment,
Extended Mag.
Beste.
Jetzt haben wir sogar noch...
Jetzt haben wir Doppelshotgun.
Guck mal, Doppelshotgun.
Nicht, dass es irgendwie Sinn machen würde, so zu spielen.
Aber wir haben's.
Bonus-Schuss.
Da springen jetzt gleich Leute raus und die werden gebasht.
Ja, guck da.
Ja.
Vielleicht ein bisschen große Range und ein bisschen schwierig zu hitten.
Wo kommen die denn auf einmal schon her?
Die Attacker sind aber echt schnell.
Da muss man wirklich auf Zack sein bei denen.
Trau mich nicht.
Ich hab übrigens geklickt.
Aber wahrscheinlich war ich zu lahm.
Boomer-Reflexe, Leute.
Bald 39, da geht sowas nicht mehr.
Too late.
Spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn.
Spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn.
Please, spawn.
Please, nein.
Okay.
Ist es eigentlich immer noch unsinnig in dem Spiel als Jet zu spawnen,
weil man besseren Fahrzeugen den Slot wegnimmt?
Oder haben die das mittlerweile gefixt?
Ich glaube, auf B gehen die nicht.
Die sehen ja richtig scharf hier, die Gegner.
Auf uns.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die da noch drin sind.
Scheint nicht so.
Okay.
Okay, ich glaube, den ersten Angriff haben wir erstmal.
Die waren saumäßig schnell.
Das hätte auch fast geklappt.
Jetzt campen sie einfach ein bisschen in der Base rum.
Nice.
Äh, was?
Wir können sie aber nicht auswählen, weil wir den Chat nutzen können.
Wir einschalten.
Ja.
Ist halt...
Fail, ne?
Oh, hier kommt ein Auto.
Das ist unserer.
Wait a minute.
Warum...
Okay.
Uh!
Der wurde gerade rausgesniped.
Das ist nicht übel gewesen, den aus dem Auto zu snipen.
Aber wirklich aggressiv sind die Gegner auch nicht.
Oh!
Lege Hände!
Oh, da ist ein Panzer.
Du siehst mich nicht.
Diffuse kill.
Oh, oh.
Wenn der Panzer explodiert, bin ich auch down.
Okay.
Da springt gleich einer.
Die springen immer planlos aus diesen Dingern raus.
Man muss einfach nur in den Himmel gucken und kann Kills machen.
Auf...
Sag ich doch.
Wo ist der Nächste?
Komm her, Leute.
Alter, die machen jetzt...
Dankeschön, Game, dass es nicht funktioniert mit dem Springen.
Erstaunlich wenige, die im Heli spawnen.
Oh nein.
Okay.
Ich bin noch drin.
Gib ihm.
Alter, fahr ran!
Fahr doch!
Oh, shit.
Warum ist das leer?
Oh, wir haben es.
Pog!
Da ist noch einer.
Nice.
Ja, haben wir.
Oh.
Das war close.
Das war richtig close gerade.
Ich habe gedacht, wir haben es gerade verloren, die Base.
Jetzt haben sie noch 15 Tickets.
Jetzt haben wir es eigentlich.
Also, wenn die jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie so Wunder-Push machen, dann sollten wir es normalerweise haben.
Okay, anscheinend ist da hinten auch noch ein bisschen was.
War das ein Gegner?
Alles...
Alles dead?
Sag mal, gehen die Schüsse...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, gehen die einfach durch?
Da kommt noch was Richtung A.
War da nicht gerade noch ein Gegner?
War nicht eben hier noch in dem Moment gerade ein Gegner?
Okay, anscheinend nicht.
Shit.
Das war schlecht.
Ich hätte nicht rüber zu B gesollt.
Die legen jetzt das...
Oh, shit.
Das war PP-ger.
Richtig PP-ger.
Oh, shit.
Nein.
Das habe ich ver...
Das habe ich verkackt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir es noch, irgendeins davon.
Oder wir haben versucht zu...
Kamikaze rassen, Alter.
Shit.
Das ist ein Battlefield-3-Map, doch.
Och, Chico, was ist denn jetzt?
Game.
Okay, nice.
Oh, meine Location ist revealed.
Oh, fuck.
Wir sollten nicht in der Base rumhampeln, während die hinten legen.
Okay, nice.
GG.
Die sind aber auch schnell.
Die sind aber auch schnell mit Legehennen.
Aber das habe ich verkackt.
Ich hätte an B sitzen bleiben müssen.
Das macht die Katze.
Die wollte schon gerade wieder raus.
Okay, vielleicht schaffe ich es noch irgendwie, hier rein zu spawnen.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, vielleicht komme ich noch schnell an A ran.
Sieht aber nicht so aus.
Da steht, glaube ich, der gegnerische Heli.
Okay, das war PP-ger-Aim.
Hätte ich treffen müssen.
Oh, Panzer.
Vor der Nase.
Shit.
Ich habe nichts gegen den Panzer.
Aber gar nichts.
Der kann uns jetzt richtig abfucken.
Hallo, Panzer.
Panzman.
Da ist er dead.
Nein.
Die Fuske.
Hallo?
Was?
Alter, das ist wieder abgebrochen.
Das Game regt mich heute unglaublich auf.
Ich habe mich nicht bewegt.
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Ich habe einfach nur E gedrückt.
Ich sehe nichts.
Ah, wo ist mein Steuerkreuz?
Da.
Ja, ihr dürft gerne noch mehr runterspringen.
Ja, ja.
Macht ihr nur weiter so.
Perfekt, perfekt.
Macht weiter.
Springt weiter runter.
Easy.
Es wäre halt auch sehr nice, wenn man das sehen würde, wo man hinschießt.
Ah, shit.
Close.
Ich meine, wir haben eine realistische Chance, das zu halten.
Wenn wir die Typen weiterhin ab...
Okay, den haben sie, den haben sie.
Wo ist der Heli?
Der Heli lässt sich nicht spotten.
Heli spotten gibt es nicht mehr.
Nice.
Schön in Bobbers.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Shit.
Es sind halt ein bisschen die anderen Eier da vorne irgendwo rum.
Und jetzt müssen wir hinten deployen.
Okay.
Jetzt...
Okay, gib Gas, gib Gas.
Lege Hände.
Wir haben es.
Okay, das...
Alter.
Das ist doch nicht normal gerade.
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, das ist jetzt wirklich mal Battlefield-Feeling.
Das ist wirklich mal...
Okay.
Ich habe es verschissen.
Es liegt an mir, wenn der das jetzt legt.
Ich habe beaimt.
Ich habe irgendeinen hässlichen Skin für die Shotgun unlocked.
Who cares?
Und schnell wieder hin.
Gib Gas, Alter.
Gib Gas.
Bunnyhoppe.
70 Meter.
60 Meter.
Es sind, glaube ich, relativ viele von uns da.
Oh, da ist ein Panzer.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Wo?
Okay, der Heli-Typ.
Okay, den darf ich wieder nicht spotten, weil er zu hoch ist.
Warum können Helis eigentlich zu hoch zum Spotten sein?
Jo, gibt keine Treffer.
Treffer ist overrated.
She baited.
Nein!
Okay, wir machen...
Oh, der kacke Heli.
Okay.
Wir können das...
Oh, nice!
Wollte gerade sagen, es wird sehr close.
Aber das war mal eine schöne Runde Battlefield, Alter.
Das war wirklich mal was.
Mag vielleicht ja auch an der Map liegen, dass dir halt einfach was taugt für Rush.
Aber das war wenigstens mal eine schöne Runde Battlefield.
Es war die ganze Zeit Action.
Du hast teilweise gedacht, du verreckst und hast dann doch noch drei gekillt.
Das war wirklich eine nice Runde wieder.
Und es haben auch alle Objective gespielt.
Hätte ich nicht Objective gespielt und mir außenrum gestellt, hätte ich vielleicht zehn mehr Kills gemacht, aber wir hätten das M-Comp verloren.
Boah, das ist nice.
Sehr schick.
Sehr, sehr, sehr schick.
Pog!
Continue.
So, was habe ich denn unlockt?
Gibt es vielleicht gescheite Aufsätze für die MTA?
Achso, ne, ich habe ja MTA so mit wenig gespielt.
Hoffe, dass Battlefield 7 Rush hat.
Vielleicht nennen sie es ja auch Battlefield 6.
Weil...
Battlefield 6 haben sie sich ja quasi gespart jetzt.
Mit 2042.
Ich habe einen Holosight für eine Shotgun.
Ja, unsinniger geht es nicht mehr, oder?
Braucht keiner.
Sieht aus, als wäre die Wartezeit vorbei.
Okay, komm.
Probieren wir es nochmal.
Oder mal das Ding?
Oh, MTA.
Ich finde das...
Ich erkenne die Waffen noch nicht mal hier.
Schon wieder Defender?
Heute ist aber sehr Defender heavy, oder?
Haben wir irgendwas unlockt?
Ne, natürlich nicht, man.
Was auch?
Wie viele Kills haben wir mit dem Ding dann jetzt gemacht bisher schon?
15?
Ne, da gibt es nichts dafür.
Wann gibt es denn den Silencer, den ersten?
Hit Indicator Stealth?
Ah.
Okay, hier muss man sich gleich beeilen für Orbital.
Guck, die sind schon dran.
What?
Man darf nicht zu spät spawnen.
Das hier in Orbital ist tödlich.
Du musst direkt an A oben am Berg stehen.
Sonst ist...
Ja, du musst direkt...
Oh, shit.
Da kommt ganz viel jetzt.
Ah, shit.
Das haben sie überrannt.
Du musst direkt oben am Berg stehen.
Defense Orbital.
Sonst bist du...
Sonst bist du dead.
Zu lange.
Wie kannst du die KD bei dir einschalten?
Was? KD?
Wie einschalten?
Weiß gar nicht, ob das nicht vielleicht ein Legacy Feature ist.
Schild dude, man.
Ob das nicht irgendein Legacy Feature ist, dass es gar keine KD mehr gibt.
Leute, gibt es noch KD in dem Game?
Oh, wir haben es sogar noch disabled.
MVP, aber bringt nichts.
Wir sind viel zu weit.
Ne, ne, ne.
Jetzt haben wir auch unseren Schild dude am Start.
Ha!
Das hast du so gedacht, ha?
Das habt ihr euch so...
Kills, deaths...
Ja, wenn du Tab drückst.
Ja, das weiß ich.
Und die overall KD.
Weiß ich nicht, ob es Statistiken gibt in dem Spiel mittlerweile.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, Leute.
Ich brauche wieder irgendwas über Range.
Suckt gerade richtig.
Hat man hier auch einen richtigen Schalldämpfer?
Minimap Stealth...
Auf allen...
Ranges?
Jetzt werden die Plays rausgeholt.
Nice. Sehr gut, Max.
Wieder mal schön Dauerfeuer, wo man nichts trifft.
Die Runde läuft es richtig, Leute.
Jetzt gehen sie zu B.
Sind an B abgesprungen.
Machen jetzt gleich Legehenne.
Wie mich die Gegner abfacken gerade.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Was ist das hier irgendwie?
ESL Final wieder.
Alter, der Typ ist ja nervig.
Was macht man gegen den Schildkerl?
Kann man das irgendwie messern?
Oder was ist da die Taktik?
Ich sehe den so gut wie nie.
Was ist da die High IQ Taktik?
Drumherum rennen?
Okay, wir holten die Linie.
Dass die hier nicht lagern...
Oh, die... Ja, ja, ja.
Da muss ich auf die Seite.
Shit, shit, shit.
Oh, hier kommen viel zu viele, viel zu viele.
Eins zurück.
Und jetzt links gucken.
Alter!
Max!
Was ist denn mit Happen?
Hör doch auf mit dem Dauerfeuer Blödsinn.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht abgewöhnen.
Man trifft mit dem Ding nichts mehr im Dauerfeuer seit dem Patch.
Die kommen auf jeden Fall jetzt eher von der Seite.
Achtung, Achtung Leute.
Shotgun.
Oh Gott, ich bin so schlecht gerade.
In S geschossen.
Die sind auf dem Dach.
Was?
Oh Gott, da ist ja noch einer.
Fuck, wo kommt denn der her?
Okay, okay.
Welchen Operator?
Äh, den...
Webster.
Der Typ mit dem Grapplinghock.
Man!
Alter, die Gegner sind super, super scharf gerade, Alter.
Was ist hier los?
Die spielen das auch sinnvoll, ja?
Die legen sich hin an der Stelle, wenn sie erwarten, dass man um die Ecke kommt und so.
Und die sacken auch nicht.
Da kannst du nicht mehr als ein One-on-One.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, jetzt wir müssen B halten.
Irgendwie.
Game, ich würde gerne hier rausspringen, aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht gedacht von euch.
Ich will aufs Dach.
Ich muss aufs Dach.
Ich muss das ausspielen, dass ich hier Grapplinghock habe.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
Dead.
Ja, okay.
Das war bescheuert zu facen gegen zwei Sniper auf der Gegenseite.
Am wenigsten haben wir...
Sir Henry carried uns.
Ich bin froh, dass wir Sir Henry haben.
Ich kann ja...
Ich glaube, da liegt ein Gegner direkt vor meiner Nase draußen.
Äh, hallo Game, ich würde gerne Reloaden.
Dankeschön, Game.
Oh!
In den Kopf mit der Desert Eagle, jawohl!
Endlich mal einer, der das Ding benutzt.
Ich glaube, wir sind dead.
Wenn wir Glück haben, kommen wir nochmal ran, aber ich glaube nicht.
Äh.
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Nope.
Nee, hätte ja keiner funktioniert, aber probieren kann man es mal.
Guck mal.
Also Chris, du musst schon sagen, die Gegner wollen es wissen gerade.
Das ist wirklich hier...
Bin ich hier im ESL Weekly gelandet?
Sonntag sind immer die Cups.
Kann das sein?
Bin ich falsch abgebogen irgendwo?
Bin ich hier in...
Okay, letzte Base.
Egal, ich stürme den nochmal entgegen.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein paar Kills und dann gehe ich hier direkt zurück.
Oh, oh.
Blöde Idee.
Ich weiß gar nicht von wo.
Es muss ja eigentlich von...
Ich höre die.
Oh, Max, alter, wie schlecht.
PPGaim einmal in Chat, please.
Oh, da war noch mehr.
Ich höre was.
Shit. Ja, guckt, alle kann ich auch nicht erwischen gerade.
Aber ich glaube, die haben wir ganz gut aufgehalten.
ESL... Es gibt für das Game kein ESL Weekly, Leute.
Es fühlt sich aber ein bisschen so an.
Müsst ihr schon zugeben, es fühlt sich ein bisschen...
Es fühlt sich ein bisschen so an.
Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo die herkommen.
Ich höre was laufen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher von wo.
Okay, kaum habe ich da hinten rumgestellt, wird hier schon die krasseste Legehenne aller Zeiten gemacht.
Und wir kommen nicht mehr dran.
Shit.
Ah, ich vergaß, die Map ist ja so bescheuert gemacht, dass man nirgendwo hinkommt.
Mein Gott, Alter, kannst du nix machen.
Du kommst hier nirgendwo hin.
Irgendwo hier ist der Fahrstuhl oder so.
Das ist eine geile Idee, das möglichst vertikal zu machen.
Richtig Pogu-Verticality.
Worüber der herkommt.
Okay, und hier kommt man aufs Dach?
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich will gar nicht aufs Dach.
Okay, Fahrstuhldude, komm her.
Alter, ich mach da deinen fetten Bauch nicht davor, ich will sehen, ob einer in den Fahrstuhl hochkommt.
Äh, keiner, okay.
Ich hab euch gesehen da unten.
Hab euch gesehen.
Wir müssen halt echt aufpassen, ne?
Oh, da war ein A dran.
Wir müssen halt echt aufpassen auf den...
Auf den Fahrstuhl-PP-Gang.
Auf den Fahrstuhl-PP-Gang, der hier gleich wieder anrückt.
Huh, 30 Tickets noch.
Fahrstuhl-PP-Gang, wo ist er?
Huh, da war er, da war er wieder.
Oh, shit.
Aber das war gutes Timing mit der Shotgun, oder?
Nicht ganz sicher, wo die sind.
Da unten?
Nee, oben?
Oh!
Sind die auf dem Dach?
Die sind auf dem Dach.
Dachte ich mir, dass die da oben rumstelzen.
Okay, 21 Tickets noch, das kriegen wir hin, Leute.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Fahrstuhl-PP-Gang?
Nichts zu sehen.
Soll ich mal aufs Dach gucken, ob da irgendwas geht?
Ich werd geschotgunnt.
Shit.
Ich hätte an A stehen bleiben sollen, Mann.
Okay, schnell wieder rein.
Oh Gott, Leute, Max, tappen, tappen, tappen.
Okay, okay.
Wie soll ich das Game werfen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, ich sollte aufhören, das Game zu werfen.
Ich bin ganz schön am Game werfen, ne?
Der Fahrstuhl-PP-Gang ist wieder da.
36, ging aber ganz gut, war es rein zum Schluss noch.
Outstanding performance.
Okay, die erste Hälfte habe ich auf jeden Fall verkackt.
Aber die zweite Hälfte, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Mit dieser Waffe vielleicht.
So, eine Runde, also mindestens eine Runde spiele ich noch.
Mal gucken, was als nächstes kommt.
Was haben wir denn hier?
2,5 Zooms sagt, Zeit braucht auch keiner.
Continue.
Okay, Präge für gescheite Map.
Präge für nicht our class?
Erika Haber, ich weiß nicht.
Die Funs sind im Game nicht gut.
Vielleicht sind wir mal Attacker auf Erika Haber.
Attacker ist schwierig, aber es macht Bock, wenn man die erste Base schafft.
Vielleicht sind wir mal Attacker, da hätte ich Bock drauf.
Attacker, Erika Haber.
Nicht wieder Defender, please.
Defender.
Aber was ist denn heute los?
Wir haben heute 80, 90%.
Haben wir überhaupt schon mal Attacker gespielt?
Ja, oder?
Können raus, neu suchen. Ja, das machen wir.
Ich hoffe, das zieht die Leute aus der Party mit raus.
Zieht das die Leute aus der Party mit raus?
Ja, sieht so aus.
Rusch.
Was kommt jetzt?
Natürlich, die nächste Pepega Map, Alter.
Aber ich darf mich nicht beschweren, das kann ich theoretisch über jede Map sagen.
In dem Game.
Ja.
Attacker?
Vielleicht.
Rage?
Sind wir wieder Defender?
Ah, komm, warum nicht?
Okay, dann spielen wir jetzt mal etwas von der MTAR frei.
Ein Verteidiger ist, glaube ich, auch immer grün.
So, wartet mal.
Ordentliches Visier drauf.
So, jetzt müssen wir schnell da sein, weil hier können die Angreifer tatsächlich schneller als die Defender dran sein.
Was äußerst Pepega Map Design ist.
Also an B. An B in dieser Position da oben, in diesem runden Ding, sind die meisten schneller dran.
Das heißt, man muss jetzt gleich am besten irgendwie so einen Stelzversuch machen.
Ja, und dann sterben.
Weil man nicht richtig trifft.
Aber zumindest hat man sie erstmal aufgehalten, sie sind nicht direkt am M-Com.
Das ist doch auch schon mal was.
Und wir haben einen Spawn-Point, was auch extrem Pog ist.
Oh, ich komme mit der Waffe nicht klar.
Ich komme mit der MTAR nicht klar.
Die schießt, also die ist Close-Quad, das ist die bestimmt sehr nice.
Aber ich komme über Range mit dem Ding absolut nicht klar.
Ich mein, Nahkampftechnisch ist die gut.
Nahkampftechnisch ist die gut.
Aber man kann jetzt nicht erwarten, komplett alle Gegner zu ficken da mit rein.
Da oben, Solo, auf dem, äh, wo geht's denn hier raus?
Wo ist hier der Exit?
Dadurch, dass ich keinen Schalldämpfer habe, wissen die halt auch, wo ich bin.
Habe ich quasi wieder das Game geworfen.
Wieder, wieder geworfen.
Oh, wir haben es sogar undiffused.
Aber, nope, keine Chance.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein paar Kills, aber mehr kommen wir nicht, man.
Und jetzt, und diesmal verteidigen wir hier gleich an der richtigen Stelle.
Äh, kannst du nicht, fuck.
Das Werfen fängt immer klein an, ja.
Ich komme mit dem Ding nicht klar, keine Ahnung.
Wir spielen irgendwas anderes.
Egal, ich muss die Sachen anlocken.
So, beste Leute, jetzt, ich zeig's euch jetzt mal.
Also, was ich eigentlich machen wollte,
Moment, ich muss hoch, das stimmt hier gar nicht.
Was ich eigentlich machen wollte, ist folgendes.
Man kann über diese Türen drüber.
So.
Und nicht nur auf die, sondern auf die andere Seite hier neben an der Tür auch.
Und das ist halt extrem OP, weil da keiner drauf guckt.
Und du kannst dir von oben den Kopf sprengen.
Hier, hier oben sieht nicht so aus, aber hier oben geht es auch.
Wollte ich vielleicht lieber Burst spielen? Ist die da besser?
Nee.
Okay, wo ist hier was?
Da ist was.
Alter, ich komme mit dem Ding nicht klar.
Ich kann mit der Waffe nicht spielen, das ist unmöglich.
Für mich, also.
Oh, shit.
Ja, hab ich nicht gesehen.
AK ist die neue Meta.
Jetzt wirklich, eben hat mir einer erzählt, M-Type ist die neue Meta.
Ja, was denn nun?
Ich komme, also, dann probiere ich lieber die AK aus,
weil ich komme mit der M-Type überhaupt nicht klar.
Ah, shit, Alter.
Weniger jammern, mehr bashen.
Ja, aber da brauche ich erstmal eine Waffe zum Bashen.
Was macht denn das Ding da drinnen?
Okay, zwei Stück schon mal gekillt.
Das geht, da geht was, da geht was.
Immer, immer schön hier unten im Panzerauto spawnen.
Perfekt.
Au.
Nice.
Gute Position.
Oh, oh.
Oh, von da unten, shit, Alter.
Jetzt müsste ich meinen Türstehtrick machen gleich.
Das ist mir zu viel.
Da blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Das ist für meinen Boomer hier und macht das gerade nicht mit.
Aber der Wagen hier unten ist richtig Pork Position.
Eine richtige Pork Position.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Das ist einfach zu viel.
Nee, die ACR ist echt nicht meins gewesen.
Also, M416 ist nicht mein Ding.
Also, M416 ist geil.
Die AN-91 ist geil.
Die M5 finde ich ganz gut.
Okay, wir müssen das anders machen.
Fuck, Alter, da steht ein Panzer.
Na gut.
Okay, ich möchte gewinnen.
Also spielen wir was Gescheites.
Vielleicht komme ich da noch rein, Lul.
Das wäre es jetzt.
Mitten in die Gegner.
Okay, nice, nice Position.
Was ist denn das hier?
Zack, zack.
Äh, while moving, okay, okay.
So.
Sobald du hier was rüber stellst, ist es dead.
Kein Bock, dass wir wieder so schnell die M-Comps verlieren.
Anscheinend kommen sie diesmal nicht übers Dach.
Okay, hier ist auch nichts.
This game, she baited me.
Äh, ist da gerade runtergefallen von der Zipline?
Nein, lege Hände.
Äh, shit, Alter, wie kommt man hier überhaupt hoch?
Okay, nice.
It's been destroyed.
Leute, ich habe aufgehört zu schießen, weil ich dachte, der ist tot.
Aber der hat ein Bodyplate drin gehabt.
Doof, weil das nicht so predictable ist.
Aber da bin ich selber dran schuld.
Shit, wir sind nicht oben auf dem Dach.
Wir spawnen unten, dankeschön, Game.
Äh.
Darf ich vielleicht, oh nice, wir können den Heli stellen.
Okay, nice.
Ich fass es nicht.
Alter, das ist ja Wahnsinn, äh.
Das ist ja wie die Ameisen.
Ja, dead, wir haben verloren, nice.
Ja, flieg halt hoch.
Ja, flieg halt hoch, Alter.
Jawohl.
Nein, hat er keinen Bock.
Wird nicht hochgeflogen.
Alle Waffen sind ganz okay.
Weiß nicht, also ich habe den Eindruck,
dass die Assault Rifles seit dem Patch
ein bisschen sehr in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden.
Oder wurden.
Weil sie diese neue Mechanik ja irgendwie eingebaut haben,
aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen
das nur für Assault Rifles gemacht haben.
Du warst im Gegnerteam, nice.
Pog.
Es ist halt ein bisschen merkwürdig,
dass man eine neue Technik, also eine neue Waffen,
ja, Handling, Mechanik einbaut
und das nur für eine Waffenkategorie zum Erproben macht.
Warum spielt denn das hier?
Jetzt mal, jetzt mal eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Hat diese, also ich weiß, dass es in ganz vielen Spielen
diese Vierfach-Sides und so gab.
Hat die in Battlefield in irgendeinem Teil
überhaupt schon mal irgendjemand gespielt?
Das Einzige, wo ich das, wo ich das kenne,
ist, was eine Zeit lang mal beliebt war,
in Battlefield 3 so einen Scope,
so einen Scope als LMG,
LMG, Bepod und so einen komischen Scope drauf.
Das habe ich gesehen bei manchen Leuten,
weil das halt richtig gelasert hat.
Aber ansonsten,
Not your candles.
Okay, wenn wir Attacker sind, probieren wir es,
ansonsten gehe ich raus und ich suche noch eine Runde neu.
Sind wir Attacker?
Ah, ne, wir sind die Armees, also sind wir Attacker, ja.
Okay, holen wir nochmal die OP-Waffe raus.
Spannend.
Das ist ja nicht ohne.
Also, wenn die Boote nicht respawnen,
wenn der erste Push nicht klappt, bist du dead.
Quasi, auf gut Deutsch.
Wenn der erste Push nicht klappt,
gehen wir einfach raus und suchen noch eine Runde.
Ich spotte mal eine Runde.
Das, was ich hier mache mit dem Spotten,
ist das überhaupt spotten?
Was ist das überhaupt,
was ich hier die ganze Zeit drücke?
Schon.
Ich spotte die ganze Zeit mit Q.
Die Musik, ja.
Au.
Richtige Banger-Musik, ja.
Wir fahren direkt in den LLV von denen rein.
So, Proximity-Scan.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Wir sind gleich dead.
Okay.
Ich glaube, hier wollte ich gar nicht hin,
aber hier sind wir erst mal safe.
Okay, jetzt, volle Pulle.
Der hat es noch nicht gecheckt.
Guck mal, die haben es noch nicht gecheckt.
Die haben es noch nicht gecheckt.
Nein, der hat mich gesehen, shit.
Nice.
Noch eine Chance zum Abspringen.
Äh.
Heli-Mann, wo fliegst du hin?
Hallo.
Heli-Dude.
Flieg mal ordentlich.
Was ist mit dem los?
Was ist mit dem Heli-Mann los, Alter?
Hopp.
Was ist mit dem los?
Hat jemand einen schönen Toxic-Spruch für den Chat?
Puh.
Äh, nur vom Feinsten hier, nur vom Feinsten.
Darf ich vielleicht hier reinspornen?
Nur die Besten der Besten haben wir wieder.
Okay, unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass die Boote nicht richtig respawnen,
ist das eigentlich unwinnable für die Attacker.
Oder nahezu unwinnable auf jeden Fall.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Pass auf.
Okay.
Nice.
So, wir räumen hier aus nochmal auf, falls hier noch was ist.
Äh.
What exactly hat mich gebashed?
Machen die M-Comps jetzt irgendwie Explosive-Schaden oder so?
Ist das jetzt neu?
Wenn ja, ist das eine äußerst pipega-Idee.
Nur mal so angemerkt, ne?
Äh, ich bleib hier, dass ihr respawnen könnt.
Okay, die haben ihre Luftabwehr an A stehen.
Das ist natürlich auch geil.
Ah, so geht das, so geht das.
Oh, da ist er.
Shit, ich musste nachladen.
Fucking shit, Alter.
Ah.
Das ist doof, dass ich nachladen musste.
Okay, wir sind hier am Start, wir sind am Start.
Nice.
Keine Penetration mehr, Leute.
Keine Penetration.
Breaker, Breaker, Breaker, Breaker, Breaker.
Shit.
Oh, wie close, Alter.
Okay, ich mach das.
Die Legehenne ist in the hood hier.
Extreme Legehenne.
Nein.
Das ist so scheiße und funktioniert nicht.
Oh Gott, Alter.
Ich wollte nicht da drauf springen.
Warum hab ich nicht da drauf springen sollen?
Ich wollte liegen.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, okay.
Und jetzt, und jetzt in diesen hässlichen M-Com rein.
Nee, nicht in den M-Com.
Vergesst, was ich sage.
Keine Chance.
Jawohl, jawohl, jawohl, jawohl.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Schnell rein wieder, raus hier.
An A.
Alter, das fucking Ding steht...
Okay, jetzt haben wir es.
Huh.
Das, das war nicht ohne, Alter.
Das war eines der schwersten Legehenne-Aktionen,
die ich je in Battlefield machen musste.
Okay, weiter.
Ab jetzt geht es ja halbwegs.
By the way, 75 Tickets sind auch ein bisschen wenig hier
für den Anfang, ne.
Sieht mal, das hat keiner Bock, irgendwie das Game
überhaupt noch richtig spielbar zu machen.
Wird nichts, wird nichts angepasst mehr.
Die haben...
Die haben das Money gecrabt und das war's.
Ah, da hab ich nicht geguckt.
Da hab ich nicht geguckt, das war PP gar.
Okay, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Gut hier, gute, gute Pose, gute Pose.
Jetzt können wir da auch schön...
Okay, da ist ein Tank.
Nice, nice, sehr gut.
Okay, da oben ist irgendein Geschütz,
was auch immer das da macht.
Und das war blöd, hier raus zu rennen.
Ich hab nicht geguckt, ich hab eher auf die Map gucken müssen.
Jetzt ist A offen und wir sind dead.
Nice.
Disabled, fuck it.
Okay, Achtung.
Ich hab was gehört.
Ach, hier kann man jetzt durch.
Okay, nice, gg.
Okay.
Du siehst mich nicht, Kollege, du siehst mich nicht.
Lege Hände, lege Hände, lege Hände, lege Hände.
Was? Wie treffen die mich?
Wie treffen die mich?
Von wo?
Ja, immer noch da.
Wie haben die mich jetzt genau getroffen?
Ich seh nix mehr, Leute.
Ihr Ficker.
Ich mach euch platt.
Ich fass das nicht.
Nein!
Oh, knapp.
Hinter dem M-Com ist ein kleiner Schlitz,
ja, das hab ich auch grad gemerkt.
Huh, okay, und jetzt B, jetzt B.
Ah, shit, dead.
Disarmed, nein!
Okay, volle Pulle.
Wir haben noch ein paar Leute an B,
wir haben nicht mal viele Tickets, nur 22 Tickets.
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Die kleinen Pipegas.
Oh, oh, was kommt denn da?
Shit, Alter!
Warum dreht er sich in dem Moment um,
wo ich hier den Poggersplay machen will?
Oh, oh, beweg dich, Max, beweg dich.
Fünf Tickets, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das wird nix.
Okay, ich muss jetzt, ich muss jetzt.
Scheiße.
Ja, unser Team hat schon ziemlich gesackt,
muss man schon mal sagen, aber gut.
So ist es halt.
Leider ist es so.
Ja, wir haben es probiert.
Also, mehr konnten wir nicht machen.
First Place.
Ja, mehr konnten wir nicht machen.
Also, mehr ging echt nicht.
Was hätten wir noch machen sollen?
Okay, Leute, letzte Runde gewesen für heute.
Recht spontane Sache,
heute Abend gewesen.
Das ist Portal, nee, das ist nicht Portal.
Das ist der normale Rush,
die offizielle Rush-Playlist.
Da sind ein paar alte Maps dabei,
weil sie selbst festgestellt haben,
dass ihre Maps von 2042 einfach scheiße sind.
Ups.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis morgen, macht's gut, CU.